no time
[Music]
the time is 13. o'clock
[Music]
hey here we are once again wow the
lighting is weird in here
i guess because yeah what is that
because the window i guess you got the
little [ __ ]
little tan it's the little beam of
tennis going on there
yeah next thing you know you're going to
be [ __ ] finding the ark right i know
we'll just i wish that'd be nice
wouldn't it find an ark of the covenant
i'm gonna sell that to a museum
somewhere not gonna open it though cause
it'll melt my face off so you know
at least i'm not smart
uh but yeah it does i think the i think
the curtain was open yeah i started a
stream earlier but i was getting a
little
i guess tom's uh thing was still on and
it was like sucking down all that data
it was [ __ ] up my connection so i had
to like start over because he didn't
know what time it was i know what time
was
the time the time was uh the time was
wrong on the clock in the bedroom oh is
it yeah it's off by three minutes three
or four minutes oh well i guess i need
to fix it yeah i wonder why i thought
for him
so you know i walked in here expecting
to have five minutes and you're like
where are you
like you have one minute
watching me tie my boot it's like what
you do okay she sees those laces flying
around she's like i'm gonna get those do
you want something off do you want some
boots poking yeah do you want some
little bitty kitty boots that'd be super
cute i bet she wouldn't wear them though
the little socks
all right let's see who's here today
they're all done oh they're all jumping
in
dj maniac [ __ ] all y'all i was first on
the initial one yeah he was he was yeah
i think yeah yeah it's gonna be true
crime cheryl
yeah gonna be true crime i mean
i've been wanting to do a true crime one
for a while i like doing the other ones
too because the true crime ones are kind
of depressing but
the true crime ones
are
easier for me to do and
i don't know like a lot more interesting
i guess and i think i can't remember who
it was but somebody
uh recommended this case
and i actually didn't know about it
uh you know i had never heard of it even
though it is actually i don't know if it
is anymore but for a long time and maybe
still
uh the deadliest shooting to ever occur
in a private home in american history
yeah i've never even heard of this one
so uh was it again 1975. 1975. all right
but you know
uh let's see
zach says uh thanks for telling me about
that stuff my mom could see in tampa i
sent it her way yeah he sent me um
his mom's visiting tampa and was asking
like some good stuff to go see there
and uh you know i said my aqua the
aquarium there was my favorite thing i
used to go to that all the time but they
have like some really nice museums and
[ __ ] and you can go to busch gardens too
if you're into that
you know that's you know if you like
roller coasters and looking at wild
animals and whatnot
man what
trying to get some of this alcohol in
the system man
i'm kind of like worn out a little bit
because like like dumbasses we were
watching a bunch of fun movies last
night we watched prophecy because that's
the one we had to review
this week
yeah and then we're like oh let's watch
the original 50s war of the worlds and
those oh let's watch the 70s king kong
yeah and then we just kept drinking and
drinking and then this morning i'm like
man why did i do that i was now i'm like
really sleepy
i was on instagram talking to
subscribers and [ __ ] if
people start sending me messages on
instagram and i'm drunk oh man i'll just
[ __ ] the whole damn conversations go
on i'm talking about king kong getting
this because we were watching kong yeah
and i was like man they killed kong and
he's like well courses king kong he dies
yeah that's right
spoiler alert tom god dan don't you just
kidding
i don't even i think i fell asleep
before the ape even appeared
yeah
i gotta see it again actually i want to
do we've we've done we didn't do that
kong did we no we have not uh we've done
maybe some newer ones but i think we did
kong skull island like the new one yeah
but we haven't done the 1976 one which i
actually saw on the drive-in yeah i saw
it too so you know kong 76 was okay you
could tell it's a dude in the suit but
you know well you know
what are they gonna know what's godzilla
well in the new ones it's like oh you
can tell it's cgi well you know i think
i'd rather see a dude in a suit than cgi
to be honest with you
uh yeah a lot of people said that they
hadn't heard of this one either it's
really um
okay danny rolling ghost face this guy
is an incel yeah he definitely is on
tonight's show i recommended this case
okay so it was you i knew it was one of
y'all and uh yeah so i
yeah this is this is pretty special
listen corey because of you those guys
are really good yeah we're do and
jenny's uh working on a poster for corey
i just did yeah i found out today
they're playing in tampa on march 10th
yeah so i did all their all the posters
for that show today but um our tampa
contact who client who employs her
asked for he needed a korean poster for
that show i'm gonna i want to go see
that show if not i'm gonna swing corey
up in here
i'll uh i'll bring him to orlando i
think we well man i don't want to i
don't want to [ __ ] [ __ ] up tom gold's
thing but
yeah or mark paradise mike pereira nice
to meet you he won't really [ __ ] up his
thing but
i could get damn it i could swing them
in a mannequin
yeah maybe i mean they're on tour so i
don't know if they have like any they
haven't made dates free so i don't
really know right because i don't think
they're playing in orlando at least not
that i know of be nice to see them local
maybe bring them down to will's pub
oh yeah that would be good too yeah
um yeah we have somebody uh um yeah i
wanna gear uh what's up tom and jenny hi
glad to make it to a live been so sick
this last week i missed the side tracks
too oh man
i hope you feel better what is it are
you like what kind of illness is it
anybody seen the golden glove on shutter
so good you know i've been meaning to
watch that for such a long is that is
that uh the german one or am i thinking
of something else i thought it was
german and i remember seeing it on there
a long time like man that sounds really
good i should like totally watch that
and
i just never got around to it there's so
many movies on show i've gotten so
behind you guys there's so much stuff on
shutter that i got behind on new movies
old movies they just added a whole bunch
of like old
uh silent films and they added like 40
something folk horror movies and they
added like a bunch of stuff just
recently oscar said i got the pump no
dude i don't have the pump
i i hadn't worked out in [ __ ] how
many days has been since i've worked out
three or four days i don't remember and
i'm coming off everything coming off
everything i gotta [ __ ] reset them
receptors i didn't not taking any of my
[ __ ] [ __ ] and uh coming off coming
off cycle and everything
so
for a minute there i was like oh i don't
feel good
but then yeah that's what you were
saying yesterday yeah i was scared i
felt you know it's you go real [ __ ]
mode when when those hormones [ __ ]
vanish
your body's like
can i make you a t-shirt that says [ __ ]
mode on it and then you can wear that
like so you're like
wait a minute i'm a girl my girl what
the [ __ ] is happening oh no scared
i'm scared
now you know how it feels like to be a
girl all the time
that's what it's like yes it is it's
terrible i'm not superman i'm not
superman
when you're pumped up on all that
[ __ ] synthetic [ __ ] testosterone
and everything that looks like
testosterone and [ __ ] that's better than
testosterone you're damn near [ __ ]
superhuman if you do a blood test it
doesn't come back as a human come back
as like a [ __ ] racehorse
or like wolverine yeah wolverine you're
not human
uh red blood cells my red blood cell
count is like [ __ ] in elite olympic
athlete [ __ ] level a lot of it it
last time my doctor says man you might
need to give give blood your [ __ ] red
blood cell cow's [ __ ] super high
we're going to give we're going to give
your blood to everybody yeah and
everybody will like the blood
of the lord
my blood will
wash away the soy out of all of your
[ __ ] systems
my [ __ ] blood is the hrt like hrt
okay
billionaires are trying to buy my blood
so they can do transfusions with me
well you know you get to get pre premium
for that [ __ ] yeah if you're going to
sell it damn you sell it on [ __ ] well
you can't sell it on ebay that's illegal
but you can sell it on the on the dark
website [ __ ] i'm gonna go on some
other shits
by the [ __ ]
uh keeping it reasonable keeping it
reasonable yeah i was asking uh i hope
i'm pronouncing that right a mana gear a
moniker i won't pronounce that right
because because i said uh they said they
were sick uh not covet or anything okay
yeah that's what i was worried about
just had a stomach bug but feeling a
little better at night oh my god what
part of florida are you guys from again
we're in central florida uh eustis
specifically so right around like
orlando type area although we're
kind of a little bit farther from
downtown orlando now but uh cheryl says
tom as a chick would be weird it would i
got pictures of me as as a 16 year old i
look like a chick you did kinda yeah
well you look kind of like in in that
80s uh ambisexual kind of
like ambiguous sort of way i had people
said that i looked like uh
um demi moore didn't do me more yeah
you did kind of yeah
i got forgotten to prove and i think
he said
pictures looks like demi moore yeah it
looked like that's pretty funny
when i was like 16. yeah yeah yeah yeah
juan ortiz velasquez happy wednesday
time with jenny hey uh how are you we're
pretty good actually
um you know getting all the all the work
dudes in and out of here
doing the landscaping in the front
there was me when there's me when i was
a chick
that's man
you do kind of look like to me look at
those eyebrows holy [ __ ] yeah that's
adequate i got the other ones
four throw down says tom's blood will
keep mick jagger alive for another 100
years yeah
yeah [ __ ] mick jagger mick jagger
wishes that [ __ ] which is he with me
how old is that [ __ ] 100 he's
got to be yeah at least he just looks
100.
zach says uh just got those the metal
images of tom in a tutu with pigtails
and a giant swirly lollipop
i didn't stay that way for long you know
i got another picture of me about like
two a year two years later i didn't look
like that
yeah somebody asked how old you were so
you were 16 about 16 16. but this isn't
like
i was almost i think i was 18 then
yeah ooh colored lights yeah it's like
reflecting you can't really
[ __ ]
you're [ __ ] up my focus
you're [ __ ] at my phone
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ]
uh
yeah let me see
yeah it says i'm coming to florida to
visit my family in march i can't wait i
miss florida so much it hurts honestly
the last couple days
it's been really cold it was really cold
here like over the weekend
and i was very excited about it like
most people weren't cause they're like
no i have to cover up my plants all the
plants are gonna freeze and all that
other kind of [ __ ] but i was like 26
degrees holy [ __ ] that never happens but
then today we had to turn the ac back on
because it got hot again it got hot
again i was like god damn it oh well
winter's over
it's like two [ __ ] days that's all we
got uh yeah it's honestly
that's pretty much it i mean i i kind of
feel like
no it might it could get cold again in
february and i've and i've it's been
it's gotten cold like up for a night or
two in march sometimes but
that's probably all she wrote
um let's see where did all his hair go
shaved lob it off lost some of it
yeah
juan said i'm very handsome thank you
juan
he's very handsome
uh says i want to see young pics of
jenny too like uh like teeny pics ha ha
i think you said you used to have red
hair jenny yeah yeah um yeah i'm a
redhead naturally
uh i don't have any
i don't know i'll have to i'll have to
remember and i'll do it on the side
track shame sure goes wow what a change
tom well thank you cheryl
wow when did you get so old
[Laughter]
you used to be so cute
yeah
[Laughter]
what happened yeah damn
[Laughter]
father time got you
said on your ass didn't you
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
cheryl says don't feed tom's ego it's a
monster
[Laughter]
part of it most of it's game
just trying to entertain yeah that's
true uh did you have natural dark red
hair or bright red it was actually
bright red like coppery like an orange
red
um and it used to be really really long
like used to be like down on my butt
you think my eyebrows were big
yeah i also had a big eyebrow and the
weird thing about it is that my hair it
was naturally like this orangey coppery
red color and my eyebrows were black
yeah and so everybody thought that when
my hair was red
that i colored it because it was a
different totally different color than
my eyebrows i'm like nope that's just
what it looks like
i guess it's because my mom had kind of
like more reddish hair and my dad's hair
was black
uh so i guess it just kind of
combined i don't know
uh zack says i should let my hair go
back to ginger that color looks great on
most people honestly i've thought about
it but i don't i've actually been dyeing
my hair for so long that i'm scared that
if i grow it back out it's just gonna be
gray
you know what i mean because my mom
she went gray in her 40s
so i'm assuming that my hair is probably
also gray elio is asking if we're going
to revisit the satanic panic he was he
was listening to an older episode where
we mentioned that actually episode two i
think was the satanic pattern i we redid
it though didn't we yeah we did it we
did it a couple times yeah i thought
like fairly recent like last year
sometime i thought we did a satanic
panic revisited did we not
yeah we've talked about it i thought we
had because i remember putting it in the
poll
and yeah i'm pretty sure we did it like
in the in 2021 sometime
but yeah i just can't remember what we
talked about i think we talked about
like the mcmartin preschool case and
all that kind of stuff because i you
know we did it way back on the second
episode like back in 2016
and
that was when we were for whatever
reason we're trying to keep the show
down to an hour and i was like
so i'm sure we left out like a bunch of
stuff
zach says hey you could probably rock
gray too at least it kind of matches the
cop look
and actually for a time there was kind
of like a a trend for
sort of like silver hair you know what i
mean like a lot of like younger people
have like silvery hair so i don't know i
don't know how that would look on me
though oh that [ __ ] only looked good on
a very young person where you knew it
was fake yeah that's like on an older
person you'd even notice that you're
like damn yeah you just look like a
person
yeah you can only get away with it if
the rest of you like looks super it's
like these cute [ __ ]
17 18 year old girls wearing horn rimmed
glasses of old lady glasses and [ __ ] put
that on an old lady and then you just go
hey old lady
hey old lady it's not ironic yeah
when i was a little kid old ladies wore
those because young girls wore them in
the 50s and those were
those people who were all old now you
know
yeah
um yeah because i was thinking of uh
jade the libra who's her she does all
those halloween stuff videos and she for
a long time her hair was like bright
orange but she usually has it kind of
like an ash silvery gray but she's only
30 something so she's very very young
looking so it doesn't come across as
looking like an old person's hair even
though it is
like silver gray it looks good on her
though
but i liked the bright orange but i
guess that was too much of a pain to
maintain she just had that for halloween
last year
like for a couple months around
hollywood nah great isn't [ __ ] gray
is not the goth look
really what you would do is if you're
gonna have any gray it's better just to
go straight white
and yeah like a ice white yeah and
to do that to your hair is to invite
your hair to fall out so most girls wear
wigs
uh another thing is is a mixture of
black and white in the same wig like one
side red one side white and the other
side black
or black with like white streaks yeah
white street's going straight you know
so
the um the
the the entire
look including its hair is artificial
you can't
achieve that by natural means you know
what i mean it's a lot of cosmetics and
a lot of trickery and uh accessories and
tomfoolery and tom foley skull duggary
and uh you know they will [ __ ] sniff
out a fake and a heartbeat the [ __ ]
entire goth look starts with footwear
if the [ __ ] shoes or the boots are
not correct then you might as well just
just don't don't even try it
that's true i know it's true you can
take a very add just black
black jeans and the right [ __ ]
t-shirt with the right logo on the front
of it and put a pair of [ __ ] badass
demonia boots or new rocks or something
in your goth
you take the boots away and you're not
god you put [ __ ] black dress shoes on
there you're a poser
or you just look like a regular ass
person like a regular person right it's
all in the accessories all in the
accessories
zach says uh
meanwhile you do not look anywhere near
50 jenny so good on you thank you i've
wanted to dye my hair platinum blonde
for a while i actually bleached mine
blonde i wasn't gonna leave it like that
i bleached it blonde
before i did the bright red because i
had it bright red for a while
and i kind of liked it like i left it
because i didn't want to bleach it all
because i had to bleach it really white
and it was black so it took like several
bleachings
so i did it over like two or three days
because i don't want to like fry my hair
so i had to like bleach it and then you
know uh condition it and then leave it
let it rest and then do it again so it
came out like really really white and it
looked kind of cool yeah jane looks good
in blonde hair jenny looks good and long
hair that's parted in the middle she has
a wig that's brown isn't it brown no i
thought it was brown or reddit red it
was parted in the middle well i have a
bunch like that you were only you only
wore it a couple times i thought it was
brown no no it's black yeah there's
black why would i have a brown one i
don't know i don't know i don't know
well you could you could wear something
that was brown i remember it looked it
looked real
yeah i have a i have one that's black
and it's and it like fades into bright
blue yeah at the bottom okay that one's
parted in the middle and i have
one that's purple yeah that's like that
if she puts that wig on where it's
parted in the middle she looks totally
different totally different
if you would if you weren't expecting it
and you didn't know jenny very well you
wouldn't recognize her well when i wore
my little red wig i have like that short
red wig it's not part in the middle it's
actually kind of part over the side and
it kind of sweeps over the side like
that and it's kind of wavy and i wore
that to mannequins one night and the
bartender there like didn't recognize me
it's like he's he's like hey who's that
girl that comes with
i thought that was pretty funny because
it made my face look completely
different i've worn it on the show a
couple times yeah
i was actually gonna wear a wig tonight
but
then i thought well i don't know i'm
kind of sleepy and still a little bit
hungover from last night and i was like
i'll probably get a headache if i wear
the wig so i didn't
but maybe on friday night i'll wear one
what man i had a fan on go turn a fan on
okay
look at look at who's sitting up why are
you on your back like a damn jellybean
she is she yeah
she she lays behind us like this like on
her back
turn around and she's like
jumps up like i'm [ __ ] gonna step on
her i've never stepped on you pokey no
we've never stepped on her yeah one time
i i didn't like kick her but like my
foot went into her one time because she
ran under my foot but i didn't hurt her
nothing
uh
let me see danny rolling ghostface says
a show about that haunted elementary
school number four aka the annie lytle
elementary school in jackson florida
make a good paranormal show you know
i've never heard of that case either but
i'm gonna write that [ __ ] down because
i'm always like i said i'm kind of
running out of i don't know if i'm
running out of ideas it's just
it's kind of we've covered like all the
main stuff
and you know so
so i'm writing it down right here
elementary school
and so if anybody has like ideas for
shows and [ __ ] like that yeah they're
they're talking about that cruella
deville
look
yeah that looks cool i think like the
half black and half white yeah
i could probably do that i could be like
look like a scary old lady
trying to find who that was that had
that wig
um because i showed they're they're
talking about it and um
that girl um
um granters knows who that girl is
she's from trenton
camp guy tip for dads don't do your
teenage daughter's laundry if it has
underwear i changed out some clothes
once and thought for a minute i was in a
french cat house
weird
also he says couldn't believe how many
pairs of shoes my 25 year old daughter
has i've never been i know that you know
it's so it's such a cliche like for oh
girls love shoes and all this others i'm
not really all that into shoes
i mean i have like a few pairs that are
cool and everything but i'm not one of
those people that you know you go to the
store and you're like ooh this shoe ooh
that shoe i don't you know i have boots
i have a couple pairs of boots and flats
and
that's a little pair of tennis shoes
like for walking and stuff and that's
about it can't really think of any other
ones that i have so
i'm not really all that into shoes um
cheryl says i tend to dye my hair purple
in the summer and bright red in the
winter that sounds nice
i had i was gonna do purple for a while
too
but well i did do purple for a while
didn't i
it wasn't that long though i think i
liked the red most but
it you know it died like all the shower
like it turned the shower inside of the
shower red and all the pillowcases and
[ __ ] like that so you know
and it was too hard to maintain i had to
keep like combing dye through it all the
time otherwise it would fade to pink
so i was like maybe i'll just get a wig
so that's what i did
i have the the short red wig and i have
the more natural one that i wore when i
was fright night amy
like the red curly one
i have that i don't usually wear that
because i don't know i don't usually
wear that like with a goth outfit though
because i kind of feel like it makes me
look like the
the chick from brave
you know what i'm saying from what brave
that animated movie
like the red one yeah the red curly one
it looks good yeah it looks good
that's kind of like what my real hair
color is
actually that wig
sort of my it's mine was a little more
orange than that like an orangey like a
copper penny it kind of looked like a
bright copper penny this is what color
my hair was
but i don't know what color it is now so
i'm scared cheryl says everything in my
house has red hair dye on it yeah that
it was getting to that yeah it gets
everywhere and i was just getting i mean
black is like so much easier because it
covers up everything and
it actually makes your hair
feel pretty nice like when i dye it
like it gets really soft and stuff like
that for you know so it doesn't like
strip out your hair i don't know it's
just easier and it goes with everything
because i felt like when i had the
bright red hair i was like well
now i can't wear like some of the other
clothes that i had that they had like
green or jewelry or something that had
like green or blue or something like
that because it doesn't match because
i'm really anal retentive about matching
my colors you know
but uh
so do you want to get on with the case
are you still looking for something yeah
just go ahead and get off with it i
forgot what she calls herself on on them
instagram anyway
we see her every week
over at uh oh man that's a nice people
are you gonna are you gonna participate
in the show or are you just like gonna
fart around on the internet in the
background
um
you know who that is
where do i get wigs i usually just order
them off amazon to be honest with you
there are so many places online you can
get that [ __ ] yeah i usually just i
don't remember like the name of the shop
or anything but i just do like a search
for and i try to get ones that are like
highly rated what was the name of jenny
jeffrey's sister
the one [ __ ] mannequin she's the one
that has all the wigs
carrie carrie that's right i'm wondering
what her name on uh instagram was i have
no idea
okay
i can't help you
okay i'll find her
all right so
i'm gonna i'm gonna show um well i don't
really want to start the case because
then it's going to then you're going to
find it and then you know what i mean
she's not on here under carrie and then
it's going to be like see none of these
distractions use their real names you
got to remember what their names are
what they call themselves they're using
they're always using pseudonyms and [ __ ]
they can mask who they are
i don't mine are just me yeah i mean my
instagram is 13 o'clock but that's
because i just post show [ __ ] on there i
don't post like personal [ __ ] on there
but all of my other social media is just
my name because i always thought it was
dumb
plus honestly i would probably forget
yeah like if i hadn't been on social
media for a while like what the [ __ ] did
i call myself on there i can barely
remember all my [ __ ] passwords i
can't show it to you grabbed i was going
to show you uh jenny jeffrey's little
sister
um but
she doesn't use her real name so
can't get her oh well
well maybe you can i see a post from her
all the time yeah you just can't
remember i just can't remember what she
what she posts under
well like i said i don't go on instagram
a lot i just go on there to post no
same thing on facebook she has somehow
figured out how to be on there on under
a fake name
that weird
because they're pretty uh
they're pretty strict with facebook
about who's who fake profiles
but they can get around it somehow
well if you have a name that sort of
sounds like a real name yeah then what
are they going to do like
say no that's not really your name you
got to prove it you know what i mean
as long as you're not
you know right causing trouble
tourniquet b ass handle or something
like that i don't know why i thought of
that that was just the first thing i
thought of yeah she had a sister during
the time we were in high school
jenny would show up jenny jeffries not
this jenny jenny would show up in uh
in her damn car
and next to her there'd be like this
little girl who was probably like five
or six climbing and trying to get out
the window and screaming and [ __ ]
that was carrie
yeah scary she ended up being she's a
goth chick here
yeah we see our mannequins here all the
time
yeah
grandpa said i ran into jenny j a few
years ago she was djing at club luna in
royal oak who said that
grabbed her hammer okay yeah
yeah
for a long time she she's the
photographer for rolling stone
pokey's knees yeah
it's probably dusty over there
all right all right go ahead are you
ready yeah are you ready
let's talk about some true crime this is
a pretty [ __ ] depressing case like i
said i
had never heard of this even though
it's 11 people it's a mass murder
whole family wiped out
on easter sunday of all things
so this happened let's go back to easter
sunday which was march 30th
1975.
this is in hamilton ohio
which
i think about 30 miles from
cincinnati i think
so on this particular easter sunday what
we have
there's a dude named uh leonard and he
has a wife named alma and they have
eight children
so easter sunday uh they go to church
like a lot of people do on easter then
they uh go to alma's mother's house and
had kind of like a formal like easter
breakfast brunch thing over there
and then they go to this house at 6 35
miner avenue in hamilton which is where
leonard's mother charity lived
along with his younger brother he was
two years younger named james
what ensued on this particular afternoon
uh in five minutes 11 people
including
several children
uh all shot dead
by
the younger brother james
so let's break down
what the [ __ ] is wrong with this [ __ ]
dude
james ruppert or rupert it's two p's but
i i've heard it pronounced both ways i'm
assuming because there's two p's in it
that it's ruppert robert sounds like
robert yeah although i've seen some
people pronounce it reaper but [ __ ] that
i don't think that's right if it was
rupert it would just be 1p and that's
all i'm going to say about
so uh
so he's the perp
this is the incel that we were talking
about earlier so he's born in 1934
now
uh as a child uh i guess he grew up in a
household that was very
abusive okay now his mom charity who was
spoiler alert one of the people that he
shot later on in 1975
uh really made no
she had no compunctions about telling
him you know uh she already had the
older son leonard who was two years old
when james was born uh she had wanted a
daughter
and uh she had james
and she was a little bitter about it and
apparently was not shy about telling him
that at pretty much every opportunity uh
calling him a mistake to his face
so that's nice
uh also he his dad whose name was also
leonard leonard senior
uh was kind of like real violent
and uh didn't really have much time for
his sons
so
they uh the family when they were young
they lived in this big long it was
almost like a barn kind of like their
house
didn't have any plumbing
uh no running water nothing like that
his dad raised chickens in the rear of
the house
and during this time james as a kid
started suffering from asthma i guess he
was maybe allergic to the chicken
feathers uh and plus like just the
unclean kind of conditions in the house
overall
so he was a very sickly child
and he couldn't really you know play any
sports or like run around playing with
other kids and stuff like that
he kind of walked around like hunched
over and uh you know so he couldn't take
gym couldn't play sports anything like
that
uh also he was real small for his age
like um and he only even as an adult he
only ended up being i've heard different
things i've heard everything from five
foot four to five foot six
uh so he was you know smaller than
average and he was uh quite thin i think
even in his adult he was only like 135
pounds it's a very very small uh man
so uh that's not that big of a deal
though no i know but it's it was just
one of many things that like
kind of compounded and like i said i'm
not excusing him by saying this because
he did do some horrible ass [ __ ] but
this is all kind of like feeding into
what happened later on like maybe like
his resentment that he developed or
whatever so that's why i kind of wanted
to get into this
so uh other kids at school because he
was small and didn't play sports they
all thought he was a [ __ ] obviously
uh you know and he was real shy and
quiet introverted
and uh all the other kids at school
teased him
and uh so he was pretty much a loner
didn't really have any friends or
anything didn't do any extracurricular
activities didn't
date any girls um although he did date
one later on and that we'll see how that
worked out
um
he also was uh i guess he was impotent
uh you know so there was that too which
maybe was probably not physical it was
probably psychology magical moments and
anxiety yeah
so um
another thing that his parents would do
and his parents like i said i'm not
excusing you know him shooting his mom
and stuff but
his parents seemed like they kind of
sucked uh i will say
that what they would do is i guess
leonard the older brother
he was obviously like way better like he
was tall and he was athletic and popular
he was good at sports
and a lot smarter i guess a lot more
successful in general so his parents
would just constantly be like why you
know your brother leonard is so much
better than you and it's like why are
you so
small why are you so lame why blah blah
blah and so obviously that kind of uh
took a toll as well
so as his childhood went on
he developed this horrible uh resentment
toward leonard now leonard i don't think
was i mean you know he was two years
older the brother
and he did some [ __ ] up [ __ ] to his
younger brother and brothers do this
kind of [ __ ] to each other like i have
siblings i didn't do any horrible [ __ ]
to my siblings but you know it does
happen particularly among boys that are
this close in age
leonard allegedly uh would
like
to like tie his brother up um you know
like lock him in closets uh beat him
with a hose sit on his head stuff like
that which is bad but
a lot of if you're laughing it ain't
that bad a lot of brothers do that kind
of stuff to each other i'm not saying
that's it's not great we used to
roughhouse like [ __ ] crazy me and me
and wesley
that's what i'm saying a lot of boys do
rough now i'm not sure like if this was
way more egregious i mean it is kind of
[ __ ] up like tying your brother up or
and locking them in closets that's kind
of [ __ ] up but you know what i mean
um yeah
what
[Laughter]
wesley were fighting one time and he's
laughing and he [ __ ] ran into his
room and he shut the door and tried to
keep you from going in there and i'm
pushing on the door
and there was a little i had something
stuck in the door so it was a crack i
could he couldn't close it all the way
and [ __ ] uh
the next door neighbor was with me he's
my age dude he handed me some lysol i
sprayed the lysol up through the crack
on the door it was coming down over the
door and falling on wesley and he was
back there and almost he's deaf he
couldn't hear it and all of a sudden it
started hitting him and then also he
started busting up laughing because he
could see that i'm spraying that
i was gassing him out [ __ ] gassed him
out of the room it was just funny you
know
[ __ ] you do when you're 13 you know well
yeah
yeah grab there's hammer says ohio that
explains it driving across ohio is a
miserable experience void of even the
smallest of pleasures i've never been to
ohio but i've known some people that
grew up there and they would agree with
you um i don't know what's the matter
with ohio but everybody i know from
there couldn't wait to get the [ __ ] out
i don't know
uh but yeah so so as i said during their
childhood you know him getting [ __ ] from
his parents and then getting [ __ ] from
his older brother who was like
constantly picking on him and then
everybody at school constantly picking
on him he didn't do good in school
because he was just constantly stressed
out i guess and kind of sickly so
not not a fun childhood for the kid okay
uh also his dad would say [ __ ] to him
like you'll never amount to anything
you'll never be able to hold a job
you'll never be able to support yourself
when you grow up which you know thanks
dad uh
there was that too uh and sadly it was
kind of like a self-fulfilling prophecy
which uh that's kind of sad
now uh james robert's dad leonard senior
died when james was only 12 years old he
actually died of tuberculosis when he
was 36. isn't that crazy people still
dying of tuberculosis in [ __ ]
night well i guess it was 1947 1947 yeah
yeah i guess so yeah that's that's
that's a long time ago
[ __ ] a long time ago yeah people died
all kinds of crazy [ __ ] back there
yep tuberculosis i think polio was still
around in 47. yeah i think that was up
until the 50th well because
i've heard of like some people that are
still alive now that had polio like when
they were younger remember we were
watching i shouldn't be alive
that dude had polio and he wasn't i mean
that show was like a few years old but
that dude wasn't that old i mean maybe
he was in his 50s or 60s he's dead now
maybe that dude's probably dead though
he was the he was that that's a 15
almost 20 year old series now isn't it
yeah i don't know when this is
when the season was yeah
yeah it might be older than i thought
but it was the one where he was out in
the canadian wilderness he was like a
beaver trapper and his he went over like
a ridge and his quad flipped over and
fell on his legs and like pinned him
yeah he was there for four or five days
he was there for four days 20 degrees
below zero at night which i know exactly
what that's like [ __ ] in korea we
were getting 40 degrees below zero
and we had sleeping bags at least most
of the time we were in them but we were
wearing good equipment we didn't have
much on it's sad because he had all his
equipment but it was
attached to the quad and he couldn't
reach it because he was pinned
underneath this thousand pound
thing and he could i was like i was
watching this whole time going oh my god
but yeah that dude had yeah he had polio
in one leg so he had like one gimpy leg
and then the other leg got pinned
underneath the thing and they ended up
having to amputate it obviously because
yeah he amputated his good leg so he has
a wooden leg and a polio leg he's too
walking walking all [ __ ] i mean he
still they told him he wouldn't walk but
he was like [ __ ] that noise and he did
so he did walk again it happened to him
luckily it happened to him way later in
life anyway so
it's not like he had to live his whole
life as a young man like that
yeah there's always a trade-off you know
i was just i was watching that going
holy [ __ ] i can't even tell you what
that [ __ ] had a will to survive
though well yeah because you think most
people would just freeze to death like
the first [ __ ] night i understand it
man has slept outside many a night and
[ __ ] korean winners with the [ __ ]
506 infantry
cold [ __ ] 20 degrees below zero 40
degrees below zero insane mind-numbing
cold and it just [ __ ] wears down the
soul
even of a young man it just [ __ ] just
it makes you not want to live
i can't imagine that him being on that
ground with his belly on the ground
sucking all the heat out of his [ __ ]
belly
a man no food no water yeah and after
like a couple days you'd think oh [ __ ]
it i'm going to give up and fall asleep
and die because that would be the easy
way out yeah andy had to stay awake for
four days too yeah because he because he
knew he was at least
he was a paramedic yeah so he knew that
if he fell asleep that he would die of
hypothermia yeah and i've been in that
hypothermic state too if i can
hallucinate and everything and just that
seductive feeling of the i'm just going
to sleep [ __ ] it and other people are
like no no no i used to stay up
now i'm just going to go sleep [ __ ]
because they know you go to sleep you'll
die yeah and he knew that and he was in
much worse shape than me because he was
[ __ ] his his body was against the
ground yeah at least half the time we
were kind of standing up keeping boots
on the ground still it's sucking the
damn
heat
right out of the bottom of your boots
into the ground you know it's just
it's terrible
it is terrible you're [ __ ] keeping
each other awake at night trying to get
through the guard shift
oracle says during that [ __ ] every
year the [ __ ] north koreans get
pissed that we did that it's called team
spirit
uh civilians don't know what team spirit
is they just know it as the annual
mobilization they don't do it anymore
but it was famous back in the day north
korea did not want us to mobilize every
year during the winter that was a
perfect time to invade
and uh we called it team spirit we gave
it friendly [ __ ] names
but it was
cat and mouse game we were faking them
out like we might all you got to do is
issue out live ammo and you could invade
we weren't going to but you know you
want them to mirror what you're doing so
they spend money on it that's all you do
it's [ __ ]
but man we were nearly dying over some
of that [ __ ] some dudes did die
not my unit but every now and then every
every one of those team spirits a couple
guys died
just accidents and [ __ ] oracle says uh
the sock vaccine uh for polio was 1955.
yeah that's what i thought i thought it
was 50 sometimes uh and then uh she also
says my mom had a friend who had polio
because the vaccine didn't get to her
town until after her sisters had died
the friend had been responsible for
tending them while sick yeah it's just
yeah that's it's [ __ ] up but yeah
that's just reminded me because we were
because we were talking about this dude
dying of tuberculosis but like i said i
guess in 1947 it wasn't all that great
yeah xanada says we used to get negative
40 in minnesota one reason i move sucks
the life out of yes sucks the will to
live right out of you if you have to
live out in it we we were out in that
sometimes
60 days and it's at 45 50 days at a time
living outside in it
it's not normal folks
that's why it turned out like this
well that explains it
that's not normal
not normal that's why you turned out
yeah
oh [ __ ] that was one factor it's a bunch
of facts i was gonna say there's
probably like a lot of things that fed
into
the the legend that is tom yeah it's not
just me it's all my [ __ ] friends
my friend grock would [ __ ] wake up
[ __ ]
just out of the middle of nowhere
like he was freezing to death shivering
and he was [ __ ] it was [ __ ] 60 70
degrees 70 degrees in the house
yeah
yeah because after we got out of service
we lived together for a couple years in
boston
dude that wake up oh oh i thought it was
cold no you're not cold man it's all
right okay yeah yeah
yeah
well yeah i mean [ __ ] like sticks with
you yeah
stuff like that yeah you know what i
mean yeah
i'm sure i'm talking that dude that was
on i shouldn't be alive he probably had
[ __ ] nightmares about being trapped
under that quad for like [ __ ] years
afterward i'd be very shocked if he
didn't yeah i heard [ __ ] talking to
sergeant smith and [ __ ] oh and
not only that not only was he stuck
under the quad and it was [ __ ]
freezing cold this was in canada but uh
the place was also surrounded by coyotes
yeah that kept coming up trying to eat
them so you know that's also nice
um oh and the really shitty thing too
was there was a farm
only like half a mile away he could see
it he could see it like the light from
it he could hear the dogs barking but
they couldn't hear him
how frustrating with that he was blowing
a whistle yeah he had a wall because he
had all the [ __ ] i mean he had a compass
he had like a fire starter he had a
whistle he had like a month worth of
food and water and all this other stuff
but he couldn't reach any of it he did
have the whistle around his neck though
but yeah they couldn't hear it because
it would live the wind and stuff four
dro down set a good read that that's
weird we gotta look into that
i heard a story yesterday about two
german soldiers who were trapped in a
tunnel complex for six years after a
bombing raid
huh
that wouldn't surprise me
if they were in a military tunnel
complex that had a bunch of supplies in
it let me look that up yeah send us some
more information we're going to look
into that unless you're [ __ ]
german soldiers yeah and i mean i'm sure
i can google it if there were supplies
and mres down there and they got trapped
and there was enough supplies to keep
them alive for six years yeah
maybe they're trying to tunnel out
during that time
it's possible
i mean without
vitamin d without sunlight you can live
decades before it kills you the north
koreans put people in underground mines
for
punishment life life sentences in an
underground mine it takes decades to
kill them
and their skin falls off rashes and [ __ ]
they say it's a living hell
sentenced to death in a mine
yeah that sounds like it would suck a
lot yeah
all right so uh so the dad he dies of
tuberculosis when james was 12 and his
older brother leonard was 14.
um after the dad died uh the mom would
start beating him and uh making fun of
him and stuff and she'd kind of been
doing that the whole time
and also would encourage the older
brother to do it too
uh leonard jr who was 14 he kind of
became like the man of the house right
and my creepy phone's ringing he always
like turns around like what is that it's
a position it's a horror movie creeping
up on it like from behind
and it's like it's never anybody it's
always like a telemarketer so i just i
never answer it but the weird thing is i
keep turning the volume down
but it just keeps ringing i don't
understand like why
it's i don't know it's haunted
but yes i mean i do turn the volume down
but it just keeps turning itself back up
for whatever reason
uh so yeah so now leonard the older
brother is you know the head of the
household because the man of the house
whatever
uh so he keeps picking on his younger
brother calling him you know weak ass
whatever
and as i said james even when he grew up
uh was
fairly small he only weighed 135 pounds
four foot
you know five foot four somewhere around
there five foot five something like that
uh when he was 16
james uh ran away from home
and uh tried to commit suicide by
hanging himself with a sheet but did not
succeed yeah
if you're this size people don't take
i'm [ __ ] five foot six and [ __ ] um
most of the armed us army rangers that i
knew were about that five five five six
[ __ ] size that doesn't mean anything
it's all heart
and [ __ ]
stamina
and [ __ ] training and the reason why
a lot of rages were that [ __ ] short
is because
they're hispanic a lot of them came from
central and south america that's where
their families came from they're short
there i'm going down this mexican
restaurant and i'm tall
i mean i think i'm a head shoulders
taller than a lot of those guys
at that damn mexican
store little bitty guys from salvador
it's a mexican store but they're from
all over
central america it's all
relative
height
it is central and south america they're
short
i mean and that's just how tall they are
that's how tall they are yeah
yeah they sacrificed all the tall ones
to the [ __ ] gods
it's like you got a good one yes
let's pull his heart out
but uh go but them little [ __ ]
go ahead and [ __ ] with them watch what
happened
okay they got people's heads off
they fight and [ __ ] ms-13 and all those
mexican cartels that are everybody's so
terrified of those are [ __ ] five foot
three five foot four five foot five guys
that's that's what they look like i've
never like i we might have talked about
this before but honestly and i know some
you know women even are kind of uh weird
about oh like she wants to do to be
taller than them like when she has heels
on and [ __ ] i never really
noticed
how tall people were i guess because i'm
short myself i'm only five foot three so
most people are taller than me yeah so
it's like i never it never it never
really occurred to me that like a
particular dude was short or whatever i
was like as long as they're like my
height or taller it's i'm like okay it's
all good yeah
a lot of central and south american
women are tiny they're little indian
women are tiny yeah they're four foot
four foot ten four foot eleven they're a
little bitty
yeah so those guys don't feel little
around their own women right you know
they're
it's the same sexual dimorphism you know
what i mean the [ __ ]
the dimorphism they're different between
the sexes so they're they're the men are
taller than the women it's just kind of
a uniform thing even though they're
they're both small yeah
i don't know it never really occurred to
me to get all like
worried about it
but apparently i was reading an article
yesterday
or a couple days ago about this woman
who was
six feet tall
and her husband was five foot five
um or maybe five foot four i can't
remember
and she said you would not believe the
[ __ ] [ __ ] we get about it yeah like
everybody said she's like even when we
sent our wedding photo into the
newspaper they were like can you send us
a different photo because it looks like
you're way taller than him yeah yeah
she's like i am way taller than him and
we're fine with it what the [ __ ] it's
just like as a short guy man [ __ ]
real tall women were always for me to
easy
easy to get and it's because actually
tall women have it much harder than
short guys uh yeah much harder yes they
just i had a friend in school that was
six feet tall and she had a music she's
six foot tall she can't get a date
even six foot one guys are not really
[ __ ] dating those women that tall
they're dating little five five five six
girls you know
so um
have mercy on them big tall girls they
[ __ ] they're good you know they're
cute just you just gotta you know they
got big-ass feet though come on
[Laughter]
like that well i mean you know something
that might be into that
[Laughter]
you need
you need big feet to like support the
height that's what it is dated one from
sweden when i was in high school in
brazil i was in an international high
school
and she [ __ ] had me like size 12 feet
you know i was looking
amazing she was like six two
sitting
[Laughter]
we just thought it was a joke yeah you
know we didn't think anything of it yeah
it's just funny that like it's funny
like reading that yeah but reading that
article i was like wow some people even
in this supposedly enlightened age like
people are still like giving them people
[ __ ] about it yeah like because she's
way taller than i think she was seven
inches tall inches taller than him she
said
no
yeah i mean
i [ __ ] my i've been five six and
[ __ ] short my whole life i never
really [ __ ] saw it as a thing and
what's funny is that you'll get guys
that are taller than you and you more
badass than he is he's gonna say that
you're napoleonic i said no i'm just a
man like you it's my height has nothing
to do with the fact how i feel yeah i'm
just a badass and you're not so
you're calling me you're calling me
napoleonic because i'm sure
but i can still beat your ass how was
that napoleonic napoleon wasn't actually
and napoleon wasn't short
he wasn't actually that short i think he
was just average height it was well no
he was tall he was taller than average
uh it was just that i think this is off
top of my head it was a mistranslation
between
french measurement and english
measurement and the english used it as
propaganda
it was something along the lines of
translation was is that he was
five
french feet and
two polar gottas tall and his
imperial guard towered above him
but like five feet two pull of goddess
was like [ __ ] five foot nine
which was tall as [ __ ]
for that time and they were saying he
was tall as [ __ ] and his imperial guards
were even taller
because his imperial guards were like
six footers which was very tall in the
early 1800s you know when they didn't
have all the good nutrition but real
good nutrition yeah but uh no he was a
little bit taller than average so he he
wasn't he wasn't short
yeah
that's
it's just funny that they call it that
because he wasn't really french it was
course again yeah but uh
and uh imperial bone
emperor bonaparte actually if you go
back and look at he was a good guy it's
just that because we speak english we
inherit
a lot of british history and the kind of
the british slant of history
and the bonaparte was an anti-royalist
and was trying to reinstitute a republic
like ancient rome and the royal people
didn't like that so of course they're
going to talk bad about it
but he was a good man
he was good man
he was bizarre
okay you know he wanted to be a god in a
way
that's a little weird
[Laughter]
no it was in the it was in the roman
tradition
well yeah i know
that emperors were kind of like god men
so he was just being very european
really it was that was traditional
you know he wasn't an american though
see americans would not handle that [ __ ]
but close he was close he was real close
to an american would you like to be a
god tom
not in a way not in a way too much work
not yet not in the way that bonaparte
i mean you know it's just like nah no
thanks i don't want the responsibility
yeah
i'm too lazy for that
i don't and who knows he he probably
didn't really want to be a god that's
probably the spin that they [ __ ]
you're giving us you know it was
he crowned himself they say he crowned
himself he took the crown from the
public give me that [ __ ] you know
because he earned it which okay
he had a french ego we all know frogs
are [ __ ] egotistical [ __ ] you know
what i mean so
but maybe he just liked the angle of the
crown a certain way and he thought the
guy would [ __ ] it up i respect it
france is coming out of hard times
okay
[Laughter]
sorry i just respect it sorry i just
thought you saying that earlier i just
thought of an mst episode where they
were talking about the french and crows
like cause the frogs don't listen
it's like they've reminded me of that
they want to do the [ __ ] their own ways
you look at their guns every gun they
make looks crazy as [ __ ] it works but it
just looks [ __ ] up
mad pistols in the [ __ ] corn the
[ __ ]
that damn bullpup that they have all
their guns look [ __ ] crazy
they all look crazy because i gotta do
it the french way
well you know that's like oh we can't
copy
we gotta but that's good they wanna do
they wanna be original yeah they feel
like we're gonna do our own [ __ ] it does
work cool but they they'll [ __ ] do
backflips and bend over backwards to try
to get something to work that when you
could just say well make it like an
ak-47 make it like an m16 it'll be fine
oh no oh hell no we're french
this shit's gonna be french as [ __ ] okay
it's gonna look backwards when we're
done with it that's usually how it does
how it comes out and it does kind of it
works i'm into the french i like their i
like their [ __ ] well honestly i mean
they're obviously their uh cooking is
kind of like the center of the culinary
world
and i codified it yeah that's what i'm
saying
also i'm a big fan of like french films
yeah i like i like how i like how uh
pretentious they are i'm into it
the french were innovators yeah they
came up with a lot of good [ __ ]
fourth round says their cars are weird
too yeah the cars are weird too because
they can't bring themselves to be like
anybody else
but that's cool that's evil well like i
said that's
that's the good side of having an ego
you're like well yeah but that's already
been done i want to do something
different we want to do something our
own way
and that's really admirable i think i
like that
although i've heard french cooks think
this
say that oh american cooking oh it's
terrible i went to mcdonald's the other
day and i dated it was terrible
and i don't know if that [ __ ] was lying
or if she really thinks that mcdonald's
is american food
yeah that is corporate food yeah i mean
i would hope that nowadays yeah uh now
that everybody is a foodie in the entire
world gaming no that's not american food
that's yeah that's just fast food we
think it's crap too like sometimes you
get it like yeah but sometimes you just
want the damn big mac yeah sometimes you
want that like sometimes i want a
sausage muffin god damn it
um
our fast food chains are our versions of
a damn vending machine
would you some people eat out of a
vending machine but you know it's not
traditional american food it's corporate
yeah and you can't really judge the
entire and you can't judge american food
by just one region either because
there's a whole bunch of different
regions in the u.s that have all
different
dishes i've been learning food from all
around the world the next one i want to
conquer is georgian food i've heard that
the food from georgia is [ __ ] really
good spicy
it's almost kind of like that's kind of
like
the eastern europeans version of like
indian food or cajun food it's like it's
like spicy russian type food that i want
to try
we're gonna see oh we'll try to cook so
dj maniac is doing some uh stuff from
space mutiny bold big flank and big
mclarge huge
squ what was the one uh
speed squat thrust or something like
that i can't remember but yeah
it's funny i've seen
mystery science theater is like so
ingrained in my dna that
pretty much anything that somebody says
will remind me of like an mst quote at
some point
you know what i mean
uh let's see okay so where was i
uh hey wait up tom didn't you once say
in a live stream that you thought you
guys did have a ghost there
oh yeah weird [ __ ] have it's not really
a ghost it's a [ __ ] poltergeist
activity which is very difficult they're
very very different yeah so i don't even
think it has anything to do with it
because we just moved here to this house
like a couple months ago but um
but well that's it's you though you're
doing it
we're doing it yeah it's recurrent
spontaneous psychokinesis yeah rspk so
it just does it wherever you are it
doesn't have anything to do with the
house i get upset if things go missing
and [ __ ] and then they come back
well you've had that happen you kept
didn't yes yesterday you had to have all
your glasses yeah he's tearing this
house up where are my glasses goddammit
he's like going through my office it's
like you weren't even in here your
glasses are not in here and it's like
he's like where the [ __ ] are they oh my
god and he's like going all over the
[ __ ] house he goes outside he goes
everywhere and then he comes back in the
house like an hour or two later and the
glasses are sitting on the ground on the
ground in the bathroom
and
i was just walking over that area yeah
i didn't want anything to do with that
[ __ ] i get mad well that's what happened
remember that that motorcycle key that
you lost for that long time yeah and you
kept looking at it and then suddenly on
the ground and then suddenly pookie had
it in her paws yeah that was weird like
she was weird yeah yeah look it just
appeared like i appeared out of nowhere
like what the [ __ ] that was where that
was like it fell off that was really
creepy it looked like she had just
caught it yeah it had fallen out of thin
air or something yeah she just got it
what the [ __ ] we doing my key
[Laughter]
that was my motorcycle key yeah yeah
cause it had been missing for like a few
days i think at that point
yeah i don't want to talk about that
[ __ ] this [ __ ] kind of [ __ ] made my
[ __ ] skin crawl yeah cheryl said
tom's a ghost
recurrent spontaneous psychokinesis rspk
yep
i've had it since i was a kid
i can't control it it just does it on
its own if i could control it believe me
i would i'd be rich
because i'd steal money right out of a
bank well yeah that's exactly that
that's the first thing that i would do
if i could do that that [ __ ] money
teleports right here big stacks of it
ta-da yeah problem solved yeah
and then i wanted i'd [ __ ] teleport
it right here and have a stack
and they couldn't really catch you could
they i mean i could say i wasn't in
there they wouldn't have it would just
vanish out of a vault and they wouldn't
have a camera and they were yeah so they
just found it
i just found it right here in the middle
of it yeah
yeah that would be right there
[Laughter]
somebody just left it here i don't know
but yeah okay so where was i okay
um all right so we were talking about we
got off talking about how uh how the
dude was short and everything
uh all right so
as time goes on
uh
james's resentment toward his brother
leonard uh just got worse and worse and
this was
compounded by the fact
that leonard
was one of those uh you know type a real
successful dudes
whereas james was
less so uh james
uh failed out of college after two years
he did eventually get a job as a
draftsman but it was very on again off
again
leonard uh on the other hand got a
degree in electrical engineering
uh also really good athlete uh and he
ended up working for general electric
making a whole bunch of money
also uh
james had basically like one girlfriend
for a time named alma
uh
leonard
essentially i don't know if he stole
alma that's like a dumb
way of putting it because you can't
really steal somebody i mean you know
she's not
she's not a ming vaz you know what i
mean it's like she probably went
willingly but leonard ended up marrying
alma who was james's ex-girlfriend and
eventually they had eight
kids together
so
by the time that this whole situation
was coming to a head
um james was unemployed
and was living in this house with his
mom
and he basically was broke uh he had had
some money but he lost it uh when the
stock market crashed in 1973
and so he'd been borrowing money from
his mom and from his brother so he owed
them a whole bunch of money
and you know he was living in his mom's
house
rent free
uh because he was unemployed
but his mom was getting ready to chuck
his ass out because she was basically
like look because he uh was starting to
get i don't know if he was an alcoholic
but
he would go to his favorite bar which
was called the 19th hole cocktail lounge
and he would go there pretty much every
night and like have a few beers and his
mom would say look if you can afford to
go and drink beers every night then you
can afford to pay some goddamn rent you
bomb uh i'm gonna kick your ass out uh
you know because you owe me all this
money
so
again things it was not a good situation
i shouldn't know
okay
i should note too that another thing and
this might be indicative of some un
uh diagnosed mental illness
so james uh had a very strong like uh
you know kind of thing of paranoia
probably not surprising uh given the way
he grew up but he might have also had
some kind of like uh you know again like
mental illness issues that were not
recognized
um in 1965 matter of fact
the hamilton police department
picked him up because they found out
that he had made an obscene phone call
to somebody that worked in the public
library where he hung out
so they caught him and he said that he
had made the call
but
it was because
um
or i don't think it was because of this
but he seemed to have the idea even as
far back as 1965
that his mom and his brother
were trying to
discredit him in public
by telling everybody that he had made
the obscene phone call and also
coincidentally
uh reporting to the fbi
that he was a homosexual communist
okay which to me that sounds a little
bit like
schizophrenia
when you think everybody's out to get
you and
there's all these plots against you and
stuff this is kind of giving me those
kind of vibes he really did believe that
his mother and his brother were
um
conspiring against him and we're like
[ __ ] up his life and everything
uh he also thought that the fbi
was tapping his phone
at his house
uh and at his
and at the bar that he hung out at
um
[Music]
so
he's basically like uh and he thought
someone was [ __ ] with his car mostly
his brother
so uh
i guess like all of this stuff like i
said you know him
just like resenting his brother his
terrible upbringing the fact that he was
now unemployed he was drinking a lot he
was paranoid he thought everybody was
out to get him
and his mom was threatening to evict him
from the house which was probably the
triggering event i'm guessing like for
this incident
so
uh
in the weeks prior to
the massacre occurring
um james had he was a a big gun guy he
had four guns
and he was always uh target shooting all
the time
uh so a couple weeks prior to the
massacre he had bought like some new
ammunition and also uh they remembered
later that he had been asking about
silencers suppressors for his firearms
which
you know he i don't know if i don't
think he bought any but he was asking
about them and they remembered that
so
march 29th
was james's 41st birthday
uh later witnesses said that they'd seen
him shooting at cans with his 357 magnum
uh along the banks of the great miami
river in hamilton ohio uh he did this
quite a lot uh he always he went out
target shooting like pretty much every
day because like i said he didn't have a
job
so he would just go out and shoot at
cans like along the riverbank
later that night he went to his favorite
bar the 19th hole cocktail lounge
and talked to a woman who worked there
his name was wanda bishop
now she later said um james seemed
really depressed on this particular
night like i said it was his 41st
birthday
uh he told her that his mom was
threatening to throw him out of the
house because he wasn't paying any rent
um
and he said to her
that he needed to quote unquote solve
the problem
so he leaves the bar
at 11 o'clock that night uh and then
went somewhere else and then came back
and then the woman asked him well did
you solve your problem and he says no
not yet
he ends up staying at the bar until 2 30
in the morning which was closing
so now we're at easter sunday
so the older brother leonard uh comes
with his wife alma who as i said
remember is oh bless you poke
she's sneezing you okay
do you have a little bitty cold or
something
she's just sniffling around under there
and i think there's dust because it's
there's all wires and stuff you all
right seriously
yeah so alma was uh again like james's
ex-girlfriend from back in the day so uh
his brother married his ex-girlfriend
had eight kids with her so you know
so leonard and alma come to
uh charity's house the mom's house
and brought their eight kids they had
eight kids ranging in age from four
years old uh little john to a 17 year
old
so you know they come there it's easter
they could come see their grandma they'd
been to church earlier
they'd been to alma's mother's house and
then they came over here to do easter
stuff over here
now james uh didn't come down at first
uh he was still up in his bedroom still
sleeping because he was presumably
hungover from drinking the night before
which no one thought was terribly
unusual because i guess this was
something that he did a lot
uh so the kids go out and they're having
a little egg hunt in the front yard
and uh then they kind of came inside and
were milling around and everything
and uh charity was in the kitchen with
uh alma and leonard charity was in there
making sloppy joes for the kids to have
for lunch
and the kids were kind of like playing
in the living room
four o'clock in the afternoon james
finally rolls out of bed
and goes downstairs
now he's in the kitchen and he's talking
to
his brother leonard
about you know just general current
event kind of [ __ ] stock market politics
whatever and then he's like watching his
uh you know his nephews and nieces as
they're doing their egg hunt or whatever
now he hangs out with the family a
couple of minutes then he says i'm gonna
go target shooting
like i said this was another thing no
one thought was unusual he did it pretty
much every day
he goes back upstairs and gets his
did pookie get her own fluff up her nose
probably you know what she does too it's
like she likes to drink out of the sink
so i leave this the sink dripping like
she has a water fountain but for
whatever reason she likes to drink out
of the sink and so i leave it running a
little bit and she'll go in there and
she gets all excited and then she sticks
her whole face under there and then the
water goes up her nose and then she like
starts sneezing it's like super funny
so i'm always like be careful but she
keeps doing it
so uh so yeah so he says he's going
target shooting so he goes back upstairs
and gets his guns
uh he had three revolvers uh we had a
357 magnum two 22 caliber handguns and
he had an 18 shot rifle
then he comes back down to the first
floor
and he propped the rifle against the
refrigerator i don't think he actually
used that in the massacre
so he's walking through the kitchen he
seemed totally calm apparently
his brother asked him
apparently sarcastically how's your
volkswagen jimmy
now remember how i said earlier that
james was like really paranoid and
thought people were [ __ ] with his
life and [ __ ] with his car and stuff
one of his beliefs was that his brother
um was sabotaging his car i don't know
if he was or not he very well may have
been
but james believed it anyway
he thought that leonard had uh destroyed
the carburetor and the distributor uh
had taken off the windshield wipers you
know loosen the bumper blown holes in
the muffler just all kind of stuff
that he thought that his brother had
done to this car
now the fact that his brother said that
like i said
this is all kind of from james's point
of view and because everybody else in
the house was dead so
you know i i don't know if the brother
actually did ask about the car or if it
was just like an innocent question like
hey how's that car doing or whatever
but james took it
like his brother was being sarcastic
because he's like oh i know that he's
been sabotaging my car all this time and
that just that just proves it right
there because he's being like an [ __ ]
about it
so apparently
this
kind of like again sort of like a
triggering thing although
i don't know i'll get into that a little
bit later because there's kind of like
some there's kind of some
debate over
how planned this was
or whether it was just like the dude
snapped situation you know what i'm
saying
so um so yeah so james thinks that his
brother is mocking him
so he brings up one of his guns
and
shoots his brother
now
before now nobody the weird thing about
this like i said and i'm not victim
blaming but the weird thing about this
is that nobody
ran
maybe they just couldn't believe it i
mean it happened really really fast
basically there was um in the kitchen
leonard was in the kitchen
charity the mom was in the kitchen alma
the you know his sister-in-law and i
think a couple of the kids so he
basically shot his brother shot his mom
shot his sister-in-law and shot the
other kids like pretty much you know
really fast
and then um you know he ended up like
during this whole massacre he shot uh he
fired 31 shots
and he did stop to reload at one point
so yeah so he shoots leonard and then
alma and then his mom
and then his nephew david
and two of his nieces teresa and carol
who were also in the kitchen he just
went and just pow pow pow pow and like
shot all of them
then he runs into the living room
killed his little niece ann
and his four remaining nephews leonard
iii michael thomas and john who was only
four years old
what he did first
most of the victims were shot two times
i think once in the chest and once in
the head
um one of the little kids i think was
only shot in the chest once but he
he shot them and they fell and then he
went back and shot him again to make
sure they were dead
you know which seems very calculated to
me yeah mass [ __ ] shooting killing
everybody yeah he killed everybody yeah
that's his basically his entire family
just wiped out mostly kids like i said
so
yeah shot them all in the head or the
heart
whole massacre over less than five
minutes
none of the victims were tied up or
restrained none of them seemed like they
tried to run away or struggle or run at
them or anything probably like i said
because they were shocked and it
happened too fast and they didn't really
have time to react um because why would
you expect that you know what i mean he
was just like this quiet unassuming dude
and he always went target shooting so
they didn't think it was weird that he
had guns because he was just gonna go
outside so they didn't think it was
strange and then when it happened they
couldn't believe it
when the um yeah they said the only
thing that they found that was disturbed
was like an overturned uh like garbage
can like waste paper basket that's it
they did find the body of one of the
kids
one of his nieces and she was uh her
body was only a foot from the back door
uh and the back door was like a little
bit open so maybe she had tried to run
for the back door but she didn't make it
um you know her uncle shot her
so
nobody else everybody else was just
either dead in the kitchen or dead in
the living room and there are if you
look online there are um
they're like uh what do you call them
what do you what's that word
where you have a chart of something map
a diagram diagram
why couldn't i think of that word i'm
kidding i'm getting [ __ ] mad cow you
guys
i'm kidding i can't remember like the
most normal words uh there's like a
diagram of where all the bodies were
because this was not a big house it was
only like it's still there like you can
still see the house now but it was it's
only like a thousand square feet it had
like upstairs and downstairs and that
was like two bedrooms
so then so he shoots his entire [ __ ]
family right
then he sits around in the house for
three hours doing god knows what i don't
know what he was doing hanging out in
the house for three hours then he calls
the police and all he says is there's
been a shooting here
so the cops come
and he was waiting for him
you know so he didn't like try to run or
hide or nothing like that
uh the cops said the inside of the place
looked like a slaughterhouse
there was so much blood
splashed around the house that it was
actually dripping through the
floorboards and dripping through down
into the basement so he said if you went
down into the basement like blood would
drip on your head like because it was
leaking through the floorboards
and um i believe there are still blood
stains in the basement to this [ __ ]
day
because they couldn't get rid of them
now
again this is kind of one of those
things where
this is the type of dude that absolutely
zero people thought that he was capable
of doing something like this
so it seemed like even like other family
members uh like james's uncle
was like i don't know why he would do
this it's like him and his brother were
so close
and you know they they loved their mom
and all this other stuff and his friends
said something like like i found some
quotes from some of his friends this one
guy named arthur bauer
he said he's not violent at all i can't
believe he did it how could anything
like that happen he had no police record
he had no record of doing anything
really
uh there was also this woman this is
another thing that i found
this woman who was like a neighbor of
theirs like a family friend she'd known
them for like a really long time and um
she was a court stenographer
and she said
uh when she heard about it she's like i
don't believe it why would he want to do
something like that and even after like
everybody told her it's like no he
confessed and you know obviously nobody
else did it or anything she absolutely
refused to believe it
and she actually like would defend him
like to people like and and she you know
she would even like visit him in jail
and [ __ ] like that she just would
absolutely not believe that he would do
something like that because like i said
he was just like this quiet little
unassuming dude and everyone thought
that he was just super nice and super
help super helpful see you can never
tell you never tell which it's always
the quiet ones man you gotta watch them
uh so
i mean basically uh
you know the town this is not a big town
so obviously everyone was kind of like
the ones that actually believed that he
did it were like yeah liz we're gonna go
kill that [ __ ]
now this is unfortunate so everybody was
so [ __ ]
angry at him rightfully so
that
this other guy who lived in a town whose
name was donald ruppert who was
absolutely not related to that family in
any way whatsoever
he
got death threats
because people thought that he had
something to do with it because he had
the same last name
which is [ __ ] up don't do that people
come on he's like yeah that people would
call him and it's like he had to change
his [ __ ] name
so people would get the [ __ ] off his
case and like i said he was totally not
related so he's like he used to dread
every time there was something about the
case in the newspaper because it would
just start over like people start
calling his house and coming by and [ __ ]
like that
so james ruppert gets charged with 11
counts of aggravated homicide
uh very very uncooperative wouldn't
really answer any questions wouldn't
really say why he did it or anything
like that
uh in his first trial he said that he
was going to go for an insanity defense
so the first trial
um they held it in hamilton ohio where
the crime took place
now his defense attorney
his argument was
well obviously what he did was insane
um
you know and it's like he's been insane
for a long time which
like i said some of the beliefs he had
especially like the paranoia and stuff
where he thought like the the fbi was
like tapping his phone and like tapping
the phone at his bar and stuff like that
that's like some schizophrenia [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying so
maybe they had a little bit of a thing
there but
to prove insanity you don't have to
prove they have schizophrenia because
that doesn't make people go on mass
murder sprees insanity means you had no
idea what you were doing was wrong
that's pretty much the only legal
definition of it
so that's kind of what they had to prove
but they were trying to prove that he
was insane that he was uh psychotic and
that he didn't know what was going on
and then he had some kind of like
undiagnosed mental illness yeah and i
will chit i will chime in i don't agree
with the legal definition of insanity i
think it's [ __ ] stupid they got some
crazy [ __ ] that know what
they're doing is wrong but they don't
care
yeah i don't care that that it's wrong
they are still crazy though they're
[ __ ] crazy
just but they're just saying that if you
know that it's wrong and you do it
anyway then you should be punished
that's what it means yeah right that's
all it is right yes that's why they
that's why that's really the only
distinction they made called insane
yeah if you ask me but i'm just saying
from a legal standpoint
yeah because i mean if you did it and
you just didn't care yeah and you knew
it was wrong you didn't care but like i
said that's then you shouldn't be put in
a mental hospital because there's
nothing wrong i mean look at [ __ ]
albert fish yeah he knew what he was
doing us wrong and got off on it yeah
[ __ ] was insane he was eating
little girls he was also sticking
needles up in his tank yeah and leaving
him in there
you're crazy yeah look at that x-ray
that [ __ ] was crazy
well yeah i'm not saying obviously yeah
i'm not saying that they shouldn't have
done anything to him he was insane and
they should have executed his ass which
they did
yeah i honestly i think there's and
honestly i think that we have a good
legal definition of insanity because
you know yeah you can do crazy [ __ ] like
that which totally is crazy
but he still like had his faculties
enough about him to know what he was
doing was bad i wouldn't be wrong
i wouldn't call it insane you know what
i mean i would say that they would well
this person is not culpable
okay yeah i wouldn't call it insane no
they got insane [ __ ] that are
crazy and they know what they're doing
is bad they they'll do it they still
like it and they should absolutely
insane and punish that [ __ ] yeah that's
the way it should i think the only
time that you should be put in a mental
facility is if you clearly don't know
what the hell's going on don't know like
like if you did something and you didn't
even like things like what i don't like
understand like
you're totally delusional yeah you think
the [ __ ] star storm troopers from
star wars are coming out yeah yeah yeah
then i can understand that
which or there's something organically
wrong with you like clock tower shooter
yeah okay he shot a lot of people from
that [ __ ] clock tower up in texas he
was he wasn't guilty he was innocent he
had a [ __ ] brain tumor the size of a
[ __ ] golf ball yeah all right
he should have been [ __ ] put into a
hospital had the tumor taken out
and uh they should have kept him on
observation for a long time and if it
alleviated his symptoms they should have
released him yeah because yeah it wasn't
him that was that [ __ ]
i kind of yeah i kind of agree with you
there i mean like i said i know that
because we did a show about charles
whitman yeah and
we were talking about it's like i'm sure
it doesn't make any of the people that
got shot that day feel better it's like
you know if i got shot that day i'd be
mad too but he yeah he couldn't help it
you know what i mean that was a physical
he he thought people were after him and
he was just crazy and he knew there was
something wrong with him he went for
help and they didn't help him yeah all
right because they didn't he had a
[ __ ] brain tumor uh that is an
organic problem in your brain and uh he
couldn't control what he was doing i
like what you said on that show you said
that was kind of more like an act of
nature yeah it's like a natural disaster
like a natural disaster yeah great well
[ __ ] having a tumor or getting cancer
that's a natural disaster happening in
your body and if it's happening in your
brain that [ __ ] can go outside and cause
you to do great
why could why would you punish a person
for that that's not he's not responsible
for that yeah that's a [ __ ] brain
tumor yeah
now you know should you should treat
that person and if they check out and
they go yeah man [ __ ] that wasn't on
you okay that was that brain tumor you
seem to be okay we're gonna let you go
i'm just i i'm okay with that that was
him me too that's not that dude you know
what i mean i mean that's yeah that's
it's an unusual circumstance
circumstance but yeah there was no
malice in what he was doing yeah you
know because he's just not rational yeah
um but yeah so but that's why i find
this kind of the reason why they don't
do that is because they got
[ __ ] to take drugs and do crazy
[ __ ] and they want to punish them and
get them off the street they don't care
if they were not
because you could do you could say
alcohol did that to you
yeah it's just that [ __ ] has to happen
in certain
[ __ ] has to be reasonable if you get
crazy ass [ __ ] drunk and kill
somebody
you probably can't be trusted in society
because you're gonna get crazy ass drunk
and kill somebody well yeah that's what
i'm saying but that's how they have to
[ __ ] labor yeah you know what i mean
like yeah you weren't really responsible
for that because you were crazy ass
drunk but we can't trust you because you
get trick crazy ass drunk and kill
people so
you're guessing so it might happen again
it might happen again you're getting
locked up yeah that they they need
better legal explanations for what
they're doing
that's what i'm saying
the insanity thing is
it's not a good explanation
it's not a good description of what
they're doing yeah you should be insane
and guilty
you know yeah it's like yeah you're
insane but you're still going so [ __ ]
good
you knew right yeah uh but the thing is
you had to prove that there was some
kind of a [ __ ]
organic problem
because when you had whitman
he didn't choose that yeah you got the
you have the [ __ ]
you have the brain tumor as evidence
that he is not choosing how he's acting
now if another dude does that and says
he's crazy and there's no brain tumor
well i was mistreated
you can't really prove that there's no
evidence because a lot of people are
mistreated and they don't do that yeah
there has to be
hardcore evidence tumors
brain injuries and [ __ ]
but you know our our legal system is not
perfect you know what i mean and each
state is different well nothing is i
mean you kind of have to take everything
on a case-by-case basis honestly right
you know it's kind of like history has
never demonstrated a perfect legal
system yeah well there's no such thing
i mean you know that's just the way it
is yeah everything is just kind of like
we have to cobble things [ __ ]
together you know what i mean
um
so yeah so during this first trial like
i said they're trying to to do the
insanity defense
and
what they were trying to say they had
like all of these uh you know doctors
come out and say you know he's psychotic
and paranoid um that he was suspicious
of everyone and they leaned really hard
on the fact that he thought that the fbi
were
uh
persecuting him that for a long time
that he thought that his mother and
brother were
legitimately like [ __ ] up his life
like sabotaging his life i'm assuming
that he thought
that his mom and his brother were like
making him lose jobs for example like
everything something bad every time
something bad happened to him in his
life he
blamed them like it's this big
conspiracy against them
which like i said that's a mental
illness
but
i kind of feel like he still knew it was
wrong to like shoot the whole family you
know what i'm saying so
you know it doesn't mitigate it i'm
saying it explains it but it doesn't
excuse it you know
um but one of the doctors said and this
is a quote that i found his ability to
evaluate is impaired his view of others
is warped which that's true uh he sees
virtually no one in a kindly light
as i said you know that yeah that's true
but that doesn't necessarily mean
that
he didn't know what he was doing was
wrong
uh so they had another psychiatrist that
testified for the defense
and he said this is also a quote his ego
was just completely overwhelmed by this
rage this suppressed rage which had been
accumulating over some 10 years or more
actually since childhood that there was
no way in which he could avoid doing
that act
in fact if there had been more people in
the house they might have been killed
also
so
they're basically trying to argue that
it was just um
you know all of this stuff had just
built up and built up and then he just
exploded and didn't like know what he
was doing
uh the
prosecution however obviously had a
different take on it now they ended up
calling 29 witnesses and two they had
200 exhibits
and they said
no man uh we think what is going on
is that this whole massacre
was planned
and
what uh james was actually trying to do
was he was going to plead insanity so
that he could collect
uh
300 000
which was his family's estate as in like
houses they owned
um you know life insurance policies all
that kind of stuff because he's the only
surviving
family member so he would get
everybody's [ __ ]
three hundred thousand dollars in 1975
is over a million and a half today the
dude was unemployed
um you know and was in debt and like you
know he needed money right
so
it seems like maybe and maybe that's the
reason that he made such a big deal
about oh i'm gonna plead insanity
because
obviously
you can't
inherit money if you murder the family
right i mean that seems like a pretty
good rule to have
um but
if he'd been declared insane
put in a mental hospital and then let
out
in ohio at least at that time then he
definitely would have inherited
eventually um all of the money like from
his mom and his brother and their you
know their family
so
the prosecution argued that maybe that's
the little con he was trying to pull
and that's why he was like trying to
come off as insane so i don't really
know
if you can believe a lot of the stuff
that he said too about
uh his upbringing and [ __ ] uh i mean
there are some like outside witnesses
that said about that kind of stuff like
about his paranoia and everything but he
might have been kind of laying it on
kind of thick just so he could do an
insanity defense so he could get the
money eventually i'm not really sure uh
but the prosecution that's what they
argued
so uh basically yeah so he would have
got
two houses i guess his mom's house and
his brother leonard's house um
just any kind of like other property
like life insurance uh you know they had
all kind of different stuff so like i
said it ended up being like in today's
money be like a million and a half so
you know just just throwing that out
there
now uh so what they're trying to do so
the defense like i said is trying to say
well it was just an impulse he exploded
because he wasn't gonna do it but then
like his brother like talked to him
sideways his mom was gonna evict him and
he just snapped
um you know but
the the
jury i don't even think it was a jury i
think it was a panel of three judges so
i didn't even have a jury trial for
whatever reason
um
they didn't really
buy it uh because
it really seemed like
what one of the uh doctors for the
prosecution said and this is actually a
pretty good point like look if he had
just snapped and wanted to kill his
persecutors
then he would have just killed
his
mom and his brother who were the people
that he thought were persecuting him
and not killed all the children because
they didn't have anything to do with it
um so that's why he didn't really buy
the story and why he thought
well he must be trying to inherit the
money that's why he wiped out everybody
because obviously if you left some of
the kids alive then they would have
inherited the money and so forth so it
seemed like maybe he was planning this
now uh as i said this is kind of like a
small town i made that whole drink for
you you never drank any of it well
because i'm talking you're talking too
much you're not drinking i'm
talking
well nobody wants to watch like hours of
me just like sitting here drinking
i got the ice machine running i got the
new
high-speed ice machine running and it's
making so much ice that's not even
[ __ ] fun i love that ice machine
i just like i said i didn't even know
they made like little table tops these
little ice makers that's pretty toaster
and it just makes ice yeah
that's all it does and it's all
automatic when it fills up with ice it
goes okay and it shuts up and just keeps
it there
it's like a never-ending ice bucket you
gotta pour water in it though
well yeah i mean you can't can't make
magical eggs out of that flies out of
like the moisture in the atmosphere that
would be something but it has like
almost three quarters of a gallon of
water in it
so it makes a lot of ice yeah and you
can pour more in it as you're going
um but honestly i'm almost done with the
case so if you want like after that then
i can drink and yeah
then you can talk about whatever okay
yeah like it's kind of i always kind of
feel like oh there's not enough material
and stuff but
honestly it's much easier for me to keep
track of just one case instead of like
trying to keep track of like a whole
bunch you know what i mean
so so yes this is like kind of a small
town obviously um
and everybody was just they said it was
a massive [ __ ] the trial was like a
massive circus they had like lines
around the block people trying to get in
there they're like even after like after
the murders happened and you know for
months afterward people in the town
would like get in a cab and like go past
the house and all this other kind of
[ __ ] then like a year later
um
they actually put a bunch of the stuff
in the house
they unlocked the house and let the
public go through there so we're
auctioning everything off so everybody
in town like when they're like ooh like
looking for blood stains and stuff like
that i'm like that's kind of [ __ ] up
um but yeah so
james rupper at the first trial um as i
said the judges uh because it was just a
three panel judge it wasn't a jury
they um did not buy the insanity defense
um probably rightly so
so they they found him guilty on 11
counts of murder
sends him to life in prison because at
the time uh because there was a there
was a u.s supreme court case going on at
the time so there was like a moratorium
on the death penalty from 1972
to 1976 in the us so he couldn't have
got the death penalty so he got um
so he got uh life in prison
now
however
this first trial um
they later
uh declared a mistrial
and so then they had to have like after
an appeal or whatever so then they had
to have a second one
so they moved the second trial to
another town findlay ohio about 125
miles away because they thought that
james ruppert wouldn't be able to get a
fair trial in his hometown so he gets a
second trial
now that started in june of 1975.
now during this one the prosecutors
actually came forward and i guess this
wasn't uh in evidence at the first trial
they actually came out with like new
stuff about
how uh he'd been doing all this target
shooting like prior to the massacre
how he had talked to people at the bar
about quote unquote solving his problem
um you know so it made it seem a lot
more like he was like planning this at
least like a week or two in advance
uh so at this second trial he actually
got a new sentence of 11 consecutive
life sentences so he was found guilty
once again
but then
he appealed once again
and he got a new trial he got a new
trial in 1982.
now his defense attorney
was uh convinced that he was insane
and he actually his defense attorney
used his own money
to hire a bunch of psychiatrists
like top-of-the-line psychiatrists from
all over the place to fly in and testify
on behalf of the defense
and what this ended up doing
was that at this third trial again they
had the three-judge panel
they still found him guilty of two
counts of first-degree murder his mom
and his brother
but the other murders they found him not
guilty
by reason of insanity
and and i've been kind of like
i don't even know you could do that i
kind of thought insanity was sort of
like an all or nothing proposition like
at least from a legal standpoint it
seems really weird to be like well yeah
those two
that was first degree murder but all the
other ones no that was insanity
i guess they were trying to like hint
that well well maybe he had like a
reason
for killing his mom and his brother
whether that reason was legitimate or
not but he believed he had a reason and
all the other ones he didn't really have
a reason so obviously he was crazy when
he did that
which okay that doesn't really make a
lot of sense to me but okay so he still
got two counts of first degree murder
but all the rest of him not guilty by
reason of insanity
so he got one life sentence for each
guilty count uh consecutive
so what they did was they ended up
putting him in
essentially like um i guess it's like a
mental health
hospital like a mental hospital
so
it's in it's called franklin medical
center it's in columbus ohio
and that's um part of the ohio
department of rehabilitation and
correction
[ __ ]
is still
in there he's still alive
um
[Music]
so he's still in there he actually came
up for parole
in 1995 uh but was denied he came up for
parole again in 2015
again deny
he's up for parole again in february
2025 at which point he will be 90
years old
damn he's still alive yeah he's still
alive they put him in a mental hospital
um and he's still
[ __ ] in there now tammy's asking if
our ice maker is a frigidaire and yes it
is i went and checked
oh yeah yeah we got it from sam's
it had three different flight of three
different colors a black one it might
have four but i remember black
silver and red metallic
i got the silver one
it's got a damn fan on the side an
opening for the fan and it's got a
little shovel that scoops the ice out
and drops it into the basket you can
take the basket out you put water in the
bottom it's got a little scoop
sit there and it'll make
it'll make more ice than we can use
every time i go in there there's more
ice
we also have a little mini fridge that
has like a little freezer and it has
little ice it has ice we have little ice
uh
trays in there we need to put more in
that fridge so it gets colder because
there's not enough in there to retain
the cold air
it's got a little thing you can put cans
down the inside of the door let me start
i'm gonna go down there and get a
12-pack of [ __ ] soda there you go put
that in there we'll put some stuff in
there so it'll stay colder
but um
it's a good little ice maker i think it
was uh 90 90
is what i paid for it
that's not bad no it's not that you know
where'd you get it sam's sam's
yeah 90 bucks and now man i was like
should i get the red one because the red
one is metallic metallic red yeah i like
those i like those metallic red yeah it
was like metallic red they had metallic
red or silver and i [ __ ] went man
i'll just go with the silver it's more
conservative i should have got the red
yeah i like that they make all of this
all of the um appliances in metallic red
now i'm into it it looks good i really
like that metallic red look
if i you know if i ever have to buy
another like toaster or coffee pot or
anything like that i'm going to get like
a metallic red one uh so yeah so i was
reading a little bit about okay tammy
says she has it and hers is copper oh
okay yeah they didn't have the copper
ones
that said copper would be kind of copper
would be good too that's pretty
they may have had it i didn't see it i
just saw a black one a silver one and a
red one and the red looked really good
yeah but i was like well the
refrigerator is black
i almost got the black one but the black
one looked kind of
plain and i said i'll get the silver
it's conservative
shouldn't have gone conservative should
have got the red one
yeah always always if there's appliances
and they have a red one always get the
right one because i really like red
appliances yeah it'll sit there and you
just pour ice in it it'll go right you
can put water in it it'll go right
through the ice to the bottom and it'll
fill it up and it'll just continue to
make ice
you're taking ice out drinking it it's
and it's not big you know what i mean
it's
the size of a large toaster
it's a good idea it's got a little
[ __ ] clear plastic lid on top of it
buttons tell you small ice cubes or big
ice cubes on off
uh if it fills up with ice it turns red
if it runs out of water it turns red
i'll tell you
um but yeah so i was reading a little
bit about
sort of like the psychology behind these
types of
family killers i guess what are they
called family annihilators whatever it
is they call them
and interestingly i don't think we ever
did a show about john list did we that
dude that killed his whole family and
then just laid them all out all nice and
like left him in the house and said
that's a good story we saw that on we we
saw a whole [ __ ] show on his case a
family annihilator
yeah they got dudes that have so much
[ __ ]
they're so uptight
they they hold themselves to such a high
standard that if they lose their job
they decide they have to kill their
family
yeah it's almost like some ultra
japanese type thing i have failed
but they kill the family because they
don't want them to suffer the damn
i guess they don't want to suffer the
[ __ ] the dishonor the dignity yeah
but half of them don't kill themselves
yeah just run off right and try to start
over
which yes well i don't want you to
suffer in dignity you can suffer death
though yeah well they'll never know
that's what he's thinking you know and
then he goes and he starts over
and the [ __ ] get a new wife and
try to start a new family
but you would never know that's like
really scary yeah but it's not a it's
not
because he wants to kill the family he
does not want to
lose
yeah i think he doesn't want
to be seen as a failure in front of his
family that's what i really think it is
like well i can't raise them up to the
right standard so i have to kill him
yeah that's some weird [ __ ]
this dude um i was reading something uh
that like a psychiatrist was talking
about about these family annihilators
um and usually he says uh they're seen
as gentle and passive on the outside
but they tend to harbor so much
hostility toward their family members
um
but as long as they're getting something
out of the relationship whether it's
money or affection or whatever then
everything's fine like it stays on an
even keel but if something disrupts that
like somebody wants a divorce or
somebody loses a job or there's some
like some kind of stress then it will
usually like push them
uh over the edge and all that resentment
will come out like in one big thing
i do kind of feel like in this case
james ruppert he had some of that too
but i kind of feel like he was more
one he seemed to have
uh deep seated
feelings of paranoia deep-seated
feelings of all of his failures were
caused by
his
family
which like i said i'm not really sure
how much of that is true because a lot
of it is filtered through what he said
like what he told psychiatrists later so
i don't know if he exaggerated at some
point maybe his parents did suck a lot
maybe his brother did suck a lot maybe
they did pick on him maybe you know
maybe all of that was true
but it does seem like when it got to a
point like in his late teenage years and
his 20s and stuff i do kind of feel like
he had built up this whole thing
of resentment toward his brother in
particular that his brother was like
always better than him it's like his
brother took his girlfriend and married
her and had kids with her his brother
had like a really good job and was
really successful and had a nice house
and all this other stuff and he was just
like some schlub that couldn't hold a
job and just like hung out at a bar
every night and felt like a failure like
pretty much his whole life it seems like
so i don't know he didn't really seem to
have much of a chance i guess um he was
very small he was very sickly and he got
picked on because of that and then it
was just like compounded
but like i said not excusing it i'm just
trying to like figure out where his head
was at and i think that the triggering
incident
if indeed it was that was his mom saying
i'm gonna evict you because if you can
afford to go to the bar and drink every
night then you can afford to pay some
[ __ ] rent um and he thought that he
was gonna lose his house he's gonna be
homeless i guess and maybe that like
made him flip out but see i don't think
that he did necessarily flip out
i think that it was a lot more
calculated i tend to agree with the
prosecution on this one at his trial who
thought that he was planning this
and
deliberately wiped out the entire family
and then tried to like say he was crazy
so that he could get all the money i
think that's kind of what was going on
in his head i have to say
um so somebody said the house is haunted
as well yeah i was going to get into uh
get into that in a second
so this house in uh ohio on minor avenue
still there
and uh a year after the murders they
rented a fa they rented the house out to
a family who was not from around there
and evil horror time um yeah because
they're because they didn't know what
had happened
because you know they didn't have the
internet back then so 1976 a family
moves in and apparently i don't know if
this is true or not uh you know they
didn't know what what had happened or
they said they didn't
they were only in the house for a very
very short time and then moved the [ __ ]
out again like the amityville
so when they were asked why did you move
out so fast they said uh we heard
voices in the house and a bunch of like
weird noises like banging and [ __ ] like
that and we didn't know what it was they
thought the [ __ ] was haunted uh lights
going on and off door slamming footsteps
all that kind of stuff and they were not
having it so they moved out
uh so apparently over the years there
were some more families that moved in
whether they knew that it was you know a
mass murder house or not uh you know
some of them also reported some of the
same stuff that the house was haunted
and they never stayed very long
um then the house was abandoned for
quite a while but then
the house was bought by another family
now this might be because i saw like a
little bit of a news report and i don't
know if they still live there now but i
think this news report was like a year
or two old uh the baker family
and they moved in and apparently they
have had no problems they said really
the only problem they said it's not that
big a deal but everybody kind of knows
this house like it's sort of notorious
in this town so they're like right
around halloween you always get like
kids you know driving by or people
coming up knocking on the door or like
if they see you outside they're like hey
did you know like 11 people got murdered
in here you know what i mean so it's
kind of like they have like lookie-loos
that come and you know check out the
house and drive past it all the time but
they said it's not that bad so it's not
that big a deal but they said they
haven't had any problems
but apparently before this
a bunch of families moved in and out
because they said that
like spooky [ __ ] was going on there like
haunted stuff i don't know if that's
true or not but
that's just what people said so um
that's pretty much uh the end of the
case
so
if you guys want to talk about something
else because [ __ ] man
we haven't even only done we we haven't
even gone to two hours yet oh it's good
so it's a good show there's a tight show
jenny this is how i like them i'm almost
sitting over here and i'm looking at
pookie pants look at pookie pants what's
she doing sleeping in the chair is she
sleeping in the chat yeah with her
little feet
what you doing poop oh she's like
sitting up going yeah we're looking at
she's like don't bother me i'm just
leaving
they're in there talking about well
water and everything like that i guess i
don't know if they had anything to do
with making ice cubes or whatever but
i filter all the water here
and doesn't matter if you're on well
water
uh
she said well i had to use bottled water
you don't need bottled water either this
is what you do we have we have a brita
yeah this is what you do i got two
different filters
first thing to do is go down there and
get you like two or three
plastic one gallon pitchers that have
tops on them you want two or three of
them
and then if you have any more big
containers you want that too like i'll
save big plastic containers for [ __ ]
things okay
you should just do that automatically
get you a big bread of water filter it's
like a pitcher
and every time i'm [ __ ] turning the
tap on i'm filtering water
now some of that filtered water i'll
pour
into a into a a pitcher
so i got pictures of filtered water
in this refrigerator up here i got a pit
i always got a gallon of of filtered
water in a pitcher and i'm pouring that
into the ice maker
okay
i also have
pictures of [ __ ] filtered water that
i use for like cooking like if i need
water you don't [ __ ] get water out of
the tap to boil pasta or whatever you
get it out of a pitcher
now another thing that i use to filter
water with this [ __ ] i ordered
something from brazil growing up in
brazil we had these
[ __ ] water filters and and we and
they were made out of clay fired clay
there's two parts there's a bottom part
and a top part
and you set the [ __ ] top part on it
and it's got a filter and the filter is
like a piece of porcelain that you screw
in and then [ __ ] man that thing can
can filter thousands of gallons of water
it keeps it cool too it keeps yeah and
because it goes through the fired clay
it's always wet on the outside and the
like there's like a heat exchange thing
going on whenever you get water out of
there and it'll hold like almost two
gallons in the bottom part of it
filtered and there's a valve so as
you're taking filtered water out it's
opening the valve and the under filtered
water is going through the filter it's
two-part filter
that i got i imported that
from brazil i think it cost about 100
something dollars for that it's nice
it's very large it's very big and it's
sitting up on top of the counter right
there near the damn faucet
and you can i could pull the faucet out
and it's on a damn you know it's on a
damn hoe you know you pull the faucet
fixture out and it's and it's on a big
flexible head and i can fill it up
directly
right there by the sink and there's a
room where i can put a picture
underneath there and open the valve and
fill the whole one gallon pitcher
and um so
as long as your timing everything right
you should always have filtered water
around
and that's what you make your ice cubes
out of when these little ice machines
and [ __ ] and we have and and the fridge
has a has a filter in the door too like
it has the ice in the water yeah like we
have one like that yeah refrigerator has
its own ice machine and it has because
that's where i get the filtered water
and i just filter it out of there um
sorry i was laughing at what cheryl said
sometimes i drink water to surprise my
liver
[Laughter]
honestly all i ever drink is water
coffee and booze yeah i'm not a big fan
of soda or anything like or you know
sometimes but filtering water should be
a mass production exercise you should
have whole pictures of filtered water
that you put aside every time you go in
the kitchen [ __ ] throw it in the
brita or [ __ ] pull it out of the dam
as you won't
portuguese means st john
st john water filter s-a-o with a little
[ __ ]
i don't know look i don't know what it's
called not a crazy it's not a chapel i
forgot what it's called in spanish i
thought that was called the tilde yeah a
little thing of soap sound means sing
something you want all right st john you
can get that you can order them online
the brazilians make the best ones now i
know we do have some central and south
american
subscribers they might have some down in
salvador
you know chile and [ __ ] argentina
they might have stuff like that too but
i know the brazilian ones the brazil you
know so from well i had good luck with
the brazilian ones they're made out of
fired clay they're brown and whenever
they're filled up with water they're
constantly sweating on the outside of
the clay and it it acts it helps to cool
it so when it comes out of there it's
cooler than room temperature when it
comes out
but you can also have like almost a
gallon and a half and the bottom part
have already filtered you could fill up
a whole picture
and out of that picture you can use it
all day just keep filtering
it's just part of your routine but you
know
i'm experienced with kitchen stuff so i
i just think that way always planning
ahead saving containers if i see a
badass glass jar
i'm gonna say man i'm gonna i'm gonna
i'm gonna make that i'm gonna take all
the labels off that glass jar
i'm gonna turn it into something else
i'm gonna drink tequila out of that yeah
make it store spices in it yeah like uh
at publix we have like there's a line of
of um
of premium spices they come in a square
glass jar squared it kind of it's got a
nice little neck on it and it's got
clear labels on the front and the back
if you pull those labels off and then
take some
kerosene or lighter fluid it'll take the
glue off and then you know because it's
sticky glue you know you take it off
with kerosene or lighter fluid and then
put it in the dishwasher when it comes
out it's a perfect beautiful
square jar tall
and i put indian spices that i buy at
the indian spice store and label them
you know
make repurpose repurpose things you know
next thing i got coming is a bunch of uh
mason jars with the with the rubber
gaskets for for canning
and jarring things and making preserves
so among i'm gonna get off into that
making preserves that old school skills
you could take whole chicken you could
take
chicken legs
chicken
uh wings chicken
thighs and put them down in a jar with
some
pieces of onion or some carrots or
whatever some salt a little bit of
vinegar
and some spices
screw the top on there put it in the
boiling water
for the right amount of time at the
right temperature
and it'll cook it and vacuum pack it
inside that jar and it'll stay in there
preserve for a year
for a year when it comes out it's cooked
they say it's delicious and you can
do them
russian style or mexican style or
central american style depending on
whatever spice profile you're going
you're going for make your own mres
uh they actually like patron patrons
great i like patron patron silver
reposados i'm not i'm not into tequila i
don't care i don't like tequila i'm a
vodka gin and whiskey girl i'm drinking
tequila right now i'm drinking sam
silver tequila which is 20 for a fifth
and it tastes just like milagro silver
it tastes like patron silver too really
good
um yeah
sam's got some good liquor they're
whiskey scouts they're wixy sucks their
whiskey's terrible
but all their other booze is good and
all their other shit's really good i
don't think i've tried their gin
actually it's good i don't usually have
gin in the house i like gin yeah but gin
if i drink like two or three drinks of
it i will throw up that's pretty much
the only liquor that will do that it's
just too acidic with my stomach sam's
has everything you know they are pretty
much they have name brands and
everything but they have their own
brands yet and their own brands are good
they're cheap they're cheap cheap and
they come in nice bottles and everything
yeah the vodka we get there it's what
it's 12.99 for a big ass it's a big
bottle and it i can't tell that from
gray goose
i think it is grey goose it might be
yeah it doesn't it doesn't taste
anything different than any other you
know mid-range than skye it tastes the
same as this guys
around like sky is
21.99 something like that for a for a
similar sized bottle yeah that's almost
half the price yeah so it's like half
the price of that and it tastes exactly
sam silver tequila tastes just like
milagro silver
or patron silver just like can't tell it
apart good quality
now
sam's
[ __ ] whiskey terrible terrible
wouldn't [ __ ] with it we got it one time
like to try it out and it's like and i
like whiskey and i even like cheap
whiskey i like jack daniels okay as much
as the next person but man that tasted
like licking the bottom of an old
barbecue terrible terrible it was awful
and a very artificial flavor to it yeah
it tasted like drinking liquid smoke
yeah is what it tasted like bad i was
just like
they had a real good rum sam's got great
rum and a great spiced rum
you take that spice rum
heat it up
and then drop some [ __ ] apple juice
in it and heat that up too [ __ ] put
it in a coffee mug man that's just so
beautiful
beautiful winter time hot apple [ __ ]
hot apple spiced rum
winter time drinks beautiful we should
maybe get some of that before it gets
warm again you can do that although i
guess it's kind of late now no it might
still get cold it's only february yeah
i'm trying i'm keeping i'm getting my
hopes up
i was so excited when it like
when it froze last weekend i was like
whoo
i got an email from my mom in ocala and
she was like it's gonna snow yeah i
don't know if it did though
it wouldn't well it wouldn't have snowed
here because the precipitation was like
zero so it was cold but it was like
really dry cheryl said tequila is really
expensive in canada yeah it probably is
it's expensive here it is yeah yeah um
you know so yeah it's perfect i mean the
sam's one like you said it's what is it
20 20 bucks for a fifth for the yeah
whereas the vodka at sam's is like
literally 12.99 yeah for a big-ass
bottle
but you know i like vodka because it
doesn't have much of a taste of its own
so you can mix it with anything so
you know sometimes we don't have
orange juice or sometimes we don't have
you know what i mean so it's it's nice
to just oh we can just make some
lemonade or make some iced tea and it'll
take tastes good with vodka that's sam's
[ __ ]
silver and that's 20 or 21 21 21.99 man
that shit's good
yeah it's really good it's just that
sam's we don't usually go to sam's
unless we're doing like a big it's kind
of far from here it's kind of far from
here so
we only go there like once every two
months or something
so i mean because we're doing like a big
load because it's far so you figure if
you're going to go that far so i mean we
just have a liquor store like right up
the street like next to the public so we
usually just go there and get liquor
it's like a little bit more expensive
but whatever i usually just buy they
obviously they don't have the cheap
vodka there well they do have cheap
vodka but
it tastes like paint thinner um so
usually if i go to that one i'll just
get pinnacle which is the cheaper one um
or skye
you know sky is like 22 something like
that for like a big ass bottle
um
[Music]
tom somebody asked if what btk would
think of this james robert character
i'm gonna have to ask him when he comes
back i don't know where he went to
um
janet says when i was a kid we canned
all our meats
i've really gotten into i think i said
this on the side track show i've really
gotten into i don't know why lately
there's a whole like sub genre of
youtube videos that are people that do
these extreme
grocery hauls it's like we're gonna
make one whole week of meals for like
ten dollars
and i've gotten like really really into
those i don't know why they're just like
there's something that's like
fascinating about them to me um because
i was telling tom about it i'm like
there's a bunch of different ones
there's like a bunch of different ladies
that do it
and i'm just like fascinated white and
then usually they'll go to like
different stores they go like aldi or
dollar tree i like the dollar tree ones
the best because
who knew that you could actually like
make decent food like just from [ __ ] you
buy a dollar tree but they absolutely do
and i'm just kind of like man you go all
right
um somebody asked what btk would think
of this james ruppert
person the the guy that we've been
talking about i don't understand you
know you know no style and uh
i don't know why he killed his own
family i mean the man's supposed to be
you know
support of his bone family that's that's
how the community holds together and i
just don't understand it
i kind of figured that like dennis yeah
because he
yeah didn't kill his own family honestly
never kills him i don't think that that
would have even occurred to him i don't
understand it and why would you do that
do you have to understand that dennis
was upstanding he was an upstanding man
he's like why kill your own family when
there's so many strangers you could kill
i kind of feel you know it sounds
cynical but i kind of feel like that's
probably what he thought
it's like look at all these other
strangers that don't matter to us in the
slightest and that we could just like
get off on killing them why kill your
own family
to go outside the home that's [ __ ] up
but that's i guess that's like how they
think though
seriously i'm gonna recommend again that
[ __ ] book about btk well confessions
of a serial killer they made that into a
documentary did they not like somebody
told me i didn't know they made it into
a documentary i read the book because
sophie sent it to me
and um
btk man what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] i'm
like reading it
the book just like legitimately had to
have
sort of like a glossary type situation
in the front
because of all the weird
terminology that he used for all of his
weird fantasies and his weird plans and
i mean
it was just [ __ ] bizarro but it's in
a way like it kind of like bummed me out
but then reading it i was kind of like
well i guess i feel better because i
guess i'm
not like this so that should be that
should make me feel better because i'm
like the fact that i think this is
bizarre and horrifying
yeah janet says when i was a kid we
canned all our meats um yeah so i so
i've really gotten into because i was
telling you about this the other day i'm
this whole like subset of youtube videos
that are all people that try to do these
extreme grocery hauls like try to make
and it's actually pretty cool because
some people that don't have a lot of
money to like spend on groceries so they
give you like a lot of ideas it's like
hey look you can go to dollar tree or
aldi or something like that and just
spend ten dollars and you can eat a
whole week on what you buy there
depending on what you buy yeah and i
think that's really cool so they show
like how different ingredients like
something generic like flour or
corn tortillas or something like that
how you can use it across multiple
dishes like in different ways
and you know it's not
they don't have to do like a lot a lot
of cooking but they kind of like use
everything like they'll buy
you know they'll go to walmart and buy
like one chicken and then they'll make
like three things out of that it's like
look we'll take the legs and we'll do
like fried chicken and then we'll take
this part and we'll do baked chicken and
then we'll take the carcass and we'll
make
broth out of it or we'll cream a chicken
soup or whatever so they make like a
bunch of different things
with each ingredient which i'm like
fascinated by that as i've said before
having a background of course in the
culinary arts worked for were some
[ __ ] great chefs
and some great restaurants not corporate
restaurants [ __ ] privately owned
restaurants from dudes that were [ __ ]
really good
the challenge is not to take a fantastic
[ __ ] component and make that good
it
cooking isn't like that because if you
have a fantastic component you don't do
much to it like a filet mignon yeah you
don't because it speaks for itself right
it's just good on its own the challenge
is to take something that's not really
kind of
coveted
something that's kind of
bottom of the barrel
you take that and you turn it into
something that's appetizing and make
profit on it
now we're usually talking about in
restaurants cuts of meat that are not
real choice
things like ham hocks
you know ham hocks [ __ ] that's very
low on the hog [ __ ]
you know [ __ ] the face that
face the you know you pull the fit the
face off a pig
okay and the tongue off a pig and make
brazilian fishwater
all right but you which is great that's
beans and rice but it's got to have pig
face pig face and
tom that's a band
things that [ __ ] you wouldn't
normally be eating okay
so
poor people food that's the that is the
actual challenge thank you janet what
did janet say have a drink on me you two
thank you thank you so much thank you
very much
thank you that's 25 thank you janet yes
that is
hey victor just showed up well you
missed the case we did talk about the
case go ahead and check off now it's too
late no it's okay okay now we're now
we're essentially like doing a sidetrack
show yeah we're on sidereel because the
case that i did was like only took two
hours that's good that's good though
that's okay
so um
uh no the the real challenge with
cooking is to take things that are not
choice cuts and and not choice
components and turn them into something
that is [ __ ] great one of the uh
examples that i like to use a lot was
when i was a kid a chicken wing was
worth nothing
you could go to a store and get chicken
wings for [ __ ] nothing they were
giving them away
somebody saw that somebody in buffalo
new york saw that and went man
i could take that and turn that into
something so they fried them
like like [ __ ] fried chicken and then
tossed them in a 50 50 mixture
of [ __ ] melted butter
and [ __ ]
hot sauce tabasco hot sauce and served
them with a side of [ __ ]
blue cheese dressing and some celery
sticks and some celery sticks
buffalo chicken wings chicken wings from
buffalo and everybody's like oh my god
why didn't we everything [ __ ] great
right well the price of [ __ ] chicken
wings went up astronomically all of a
sudden the chick he turned they turned a
piece of [ __ ] piece of the chicken into
a delicacy
okay
i don't know exactly who made the
buffalo chicken wing
but probably achieved the mission which
is to take something that wasn't worth
anything and turn it into something real
popular that's how it's done
that's what i was saying on the side
track show that's why i'm really into
shows like chopped or
like the new gordon ramsay show like
next level chef where they have like
some of them have to cook in the
basement where they just have to cook
with like just whatever's left over and
not very good equipment and it's like if
you can make something good from that
then obviously you're a way better
chef than somebody that can just make
stuff out of expenses i was living in
[ __ ] past christianity my first wife
and uh we went down to
this is in past christian mississippi
went down a [ __ ] walmart
and i said i want to get the [ __ ] to
make some chicken wings i want to make
some chicken wings
and i looked at the price per pound of
chicken wings at walmart versus the
price per pounds of [ __ ] chicken legs
and chicken legs were cheaper than
chicken wings yeah and i said i'm going
to make them but i'm going to make it
with chicken legs
did the same thing you would do the
chicken wing but i made it with the legs
and i called them dinosaur wings because
you got chicken wings and dinosaur wings
even bigger
than a chicken i mean chicken legs i
like them better anyway there's a lot
more meat on there there's more meat on
it
but for a while there at least at that
in that period you could get legs
cheaper than wings per pound
so do you remember that one time when
sam's had a sale on those little bitty
cornish hens yeah you could get those
things for [ __ ] and they were cheap
as [ __ ] you get a bunch and we made them
man those were delicious we should do
that again one of these days they were
just like on sale i don't remember how
much they were but there was like four
was there four of them i don't remember
yeah in the pack i think it was four
yeah you could just feast on them they
weren't they didn't want much more they
didn't want much money for them it was
late 90s when that [ __ ] was going down
another thing that happened in the late
90s was boxed wine wine that came in
boxes that they were selling that [ __ ]
at walmart for nothing
and we would sit around just oh that's
still a thing now they think we just sit
around and drink boxes of wine
merlot
they had that merlot we sit around drink
merlot and get [ __ ] wasted on it and
a big old box was like [ __ ] six bucks
[Laughter]
that's even like kind of like a joke
slash meme thing still so still to this
day like box wine yeah we'd sit around
drink [ __ ] get drunk listen to
raspatina
drinking box violence drinking black
wine listener
listening to old [ __ ] uh uh [ __ ]
death in june and [ __ ]
that sounds fun we should do that one
night we'll get some box wine
put some of our old cds on yeah we had
that old 90s get some clove cigarettes
90s internet put like some put some uh
like red like cloths over the lamp
shades
yeah we had that internet that way
when we were starting up remember that
[ __ ] yeah i remember that [ __ ] aol
anyway [ __ ] yeah oh my god there's
another time i thought i was in the
future
i was like man i got to shop at hot
topic
from home with this card and that's up
just like arnold schwarzenegger yeah
it's the [ __ ] future yeah where i'm
in the future man
victor says i drank boxed wine when i
was 14 and it made me bisexual me
it might be my second because i buy you
something and then you get sex
oh my god yeah camp guy says they call
those wine boxes suitcases yeah
we have like six of them
you don't understand that [ __ ] in the
90s when that [ __ ] first hit the market
how cheap that was yeah they were
[ __ ] cheap
and especially mississippi prices
mississippi prices were [ __ ] cheap
and i was just moving down from [ __ ]
boston at that particular time
and i saw that big old box of wine i
think they wanted for 450 for it and i
was like 450 [ __ ] get three of them
we'll have a box each yeah yeah we're
sitting there
get through that
and it was it was i remember being good
wine i was enjoying it i was enjoying it
i had a real wine connoisseur i got a
drunk off of it you can get decent wine
for not really that expensive enough
nowadays i mean there's so many yeah
even in a bottle even in a glass bottle
yeah everybody's making it that's what
i'm saying the same with like craft
beers you can get like decent craft
beers i was never a wine snob i had a
background in sales i i smelled the
[ __ ] when it hit me um
and it i was like that wine's not worth
what they're asking for they can't most
of them are not and that got confirmed
later on when i saw a program where they
took these wine tasters
and blindfolded them
and had them taste all this wine and
they couldn't tell the [ __ ] expensive
wine from the cheap one they were
preferring the cheap wine and [ __ ]
yeah and once i saw that i was like yeah
i knew that yeah
it made all made sense they're a bunch
of [ __ ] artists
it tastes good good wine is wine that
you like to taste good it doesn't matter
where it comes from or [ __ ]
yeah i mean or what year it was made or
anything like i said you could find what
you like because you go to publix and
get like a decent bottle of wine for
like 10 bucks man it's like you don't
really have to get all like [ __ ]
fancy and i would imagine you could
probably [ __ ] pour out some boxed
[ __ ] merlot or [ __ ] you know
zinfandel like i said i'm not give that
to some of these [ __ ] one of these
fancy [ __ ] oh that's [ __ ]
beautiful the bouquet [ __ ] mess on
the [ __ ]
i remember one i used to watch um penn
and tellers
oh thank you victor jenny i bought the
church of dead girls but i haven't
started it yet oh i hope you like it i
just bought it randomly a long time ago
it was like cheap at barnes noble
because you know how barnes noble has
like all those cheap ass like hardbacks
in the front and i was like read it and
i was like ooh that i was like that's a
good title and i was like oh that sounds
really good so i bought it it was like
you know four bucks or something and i
was like man that book was like so
awesome i haven't read it for a long
time but i remember it being really
really good i'd never heard of that
author or anything so i really do hope
you like it if you don't like it don't
get mad at me okay so i'm just saying
um cheryl says she got a freezer full of
hams oh yeah i can one-up you in my
freezer i got a [ __ ] turkey oh we
still have that turkey in there i forgot
about thanksgiving i forgot about it i
got a turkey and i got another pork
that's right you bought three turkeys
yeah for thanksgiving and we've eaten
two of them yeah and i cooked a pork
i've cooked a a a [ __ ] pork butt in a
slow cooker [ __ ] carnitas style last
night woke up this morning and [ __ ]
that's right juiced the whole house
because i was like half awake and i
heard him getting up and i'm like why is
he going downstairs
with no clothes on what is he doing
yeah cheryl's talking about ham hocks
too
ham hocks are for really man ham hocks
are for your red beans or rice or your
um
[ __ ] black eyed peas or split pea
soup yeah or split pea soup yeah [ __ ]
free for y'all
y'all british people and european people
up there in the in the honky mother
motherland you will not understand
smoke ham hocks
okay it's a southern delicacy
it's the wrist of a [ __ ]
pig
smoked
it's mostly
fat
fat and
and some meat on a bone
but there's some about that particular
cut when you pull it off that bone and
you dice it real fine and put it in with
black-eyed peas or red beans and rice
it has a bacony flavor to it and it's
just
it's got some of it's kind of got some
chewiness to it
it's just
it can't be replicated
smoked
bacon can come close
but that's not quite it
uh it's just
it's just a weird southern phenomenon
you know it when you taste it
you go yeah that's it right there
it's best with beans some kind of a bean
and it's more of a seasoning we're not
doing it
to gain meat there's not much meat there
there's something about the flavor
yeah that it gives to beans
black eyed peas or red beans real good
picture says when i was talking about
the book if i don't like it i'm gonna
send you a payment request on cash app
for ten dollars
don't like what the book
because i recommended i've recommended a
book okay uh and you know i just i like
i said i haven't read it for a long time
i just bought it randomly but i really
liked it a lot and i still remember it
i'll review it one of these days because
i want to reread it camp guy says hard
to cook for two people me and my wife
throwing food out all the time i cook it
anyway because i like to cook don't care
if we eat it all or not honestly well
usually like tom will make big
portions of things like if you're going
to make something he makes like a big
pot of it but we'll eat it for yeah
we'll eat it for a couple days and then
we'll freeze it yeah i'll come back to
it later and then we'll come back to it
later because it'll last like a while
like in the freezer depending on what it
is so sometimes you know you'll be going
through the freezer and be like oh man
there's like lasagna in there i forgot
that was in there you could just like
eat it up you know what i mean yeah so
we don't we don't throw that much away
honestly no i mean we don't waste that
much i got a head of broccoli out there
growing tomorrow
i'm i'm gonna uh
take that package of chicken breast out
and dice it and then
batter it and fry it
kind of like uh kind of like general
sews chicken oh okay with rice does that
sound good but instead of it being thigh
it will be breast
how does that sound yeah that works okay
don't make it too spicy though because
you know okay all right it's gonna be
general says chicken i like to cheat
because they're gonna use hosting sauce
i got that
but i like it just about 50 50.
smoked barbecue sauce and [ __ ] um
soy sauce
yeah with a little bit of ketchup yeah
we should we should do sweeteners we
should do sweet and sour
uh i can do that i guess no i can't do
that you can't do that no all right well
no i do i do have pineapple
but i have any maraschino cherry oh
that's right if you're gonna do sweet
and sour you want maraschino cherry
juice and the cherries that's really the
that's true
if not i could do it i could dumb it
down just use
ketchup and and uh pineapple that'll do
it
but i like the cherries in it
yeah it does kind of have to yeah it has
to be like a bright red you know yeah
gotta get some cherries
cheryl says i love asian food yeah i can
go buy some though honestly i love all
kind of food yeah um
it's weird because when i was a kid
i was a real picky eater
when i was little
um
not to the extent of i don't know if
we've talked about this before but you
know lil swall
our friend
um
he's a super taster so
he like basically won't eat anything
other flavor that has flavor yeah he'll
eat like french fries
wait spaghetti like plain spaghetti and
white pizza
maybe is that it
yeah he'll eat that
um yeah that might be all he eats so
one time we were at a party
and there was cake and obviously i'm
like [ __ ] cake all right i'm jumping
right into that because it's [ __ ]
cake right he wouldn't he'd never even
eaten cake he's like ew i don't like the
he's like weird about texture
the texture of the way things look and
the way things look and he's like really
like i'm like wow
no cake yeah
god he's got mental problems how do you
live without cake he'll eat pot he'll
eat what popcorn oh yeah he'll eat
popcorn too yeah i forgot about that
it's like it's like white things with
not a lot of flavor yeah
and like
although he did say i remember like a
while back he said he was really
interested to try lobster yeah because
it looked good to him and smelled good
yeah and i was kind of like maybe we
need to get him see i wasn't that bad
right like um i think it was mostly
because i grew up i mean i grew up like
fairly poor
so we didn't really so we had like a lot
of prepared foods we had like a lot of
you know stuff that wasn't really
all that good or all that nutritious
so i didn't really get a lot of
you know we didn't really eat a lot of
asian food we didn't eat any indian food
we didn't eat any like thing like that
so when i was a kid it's basically like
well you know i'm gonna eat a little bit
of meat and some mashed potatoes and
like i said all the vegetables
you know were cooked to [ __ ] and were
slimy so i didn't want them
because they looked
and smelled gross well that was that old
school southerner yes so it's kind of
like so honestly like when i but then
when i got older like when i was a kid i
wouldn't even i wouldn't eat tomatoes i
would eat mushrooms nothing like that
which are now like two of my favorite
things ever
um so it's like crazy to think that all
of the stuff that i wouldn't eat when i
was a kid and now i'll eat pretty much
anything even you even got me over my
phobia about peas
yeah because i had a thing
i was so grossed out by peas i couldn't
even like
when i was a kid i couldn't even like
look at them because sometimes my
grandma or my mom would make them
and tell them how i got you over that
[ __ ] well that's what i'm saying and i
was i was just i was disgusted by them
it's like i didn't like the smell i
didn't like the way they looked i didn't
like their like squishiness i was just
like even looking at that made me want
to hurl right like
for a long time like from my kid from up
until my teenage years
and you know even when i was in my 20s
i'm just like no thank you um i just
can't and honestly when i went to the uk
because they have mushy peas there
and i went to a british pub one time and
got like fish and chips and it came with
mushy peas and i was like do not put
mushy peas on my plate because i will
not be able to eat the rest of the stuff
because i will be so disgusted we'll get
to the point why yeah well
excuse me
but yeah no i'm just trying to like okay
in a picture okay i was really really
grossed out by them
so for a long time so tom says i'm gonna
get you over that and i was like yeah
good luck with that
because they really really disgust me so
he started he made well the first thing
that you made that really got me over
was split pea soup he made it in a crock
pot yeah and he's like because at first
i was like i'm absolutely not super real
ham i'm like i'm absolutely not eating
that yeah with ham um but he made it a
crock pot he's like it doesn't even look
like peas you know they're all blended
up it's fine it's it's soup it's got ham
in it it's delicious
right diced up [ __ ] ham off a spiral
cut damn
it was [ __ ] beautiful
it was beautiful it was beautiful yeah
and so then like so i reluctantly was
like okay i'll try some
uh we'll see how it is and it was so
good that i was just kind of like oh
okay well [ __ ] what the i've been
missing like all this stuff early now
it's still it took me a little bit
longer to get past like like an actual
pea in something because a lot of indian
food has peas in it like not and they're
not blended up um so it took me a little
while to get past that because i was
always kind of grossed out by like
biting them and then going choke and i
was just like oh pee in a bean it's the
same thing well i wasn't a big fan of
beans either but i didn't really have
the the aversion to them that i have in
her face is she's covering her face yeah
she's like oh
look at her look at her look at her over
here
i'm sorry pookie are we offending you
she's like oh my god you guys seriously
i'm trying to sleep over here
you guys are just talking and yeah yeah
she's going
yeah she's trying to drop it out of
existence she's sleeping in the chairs
like with her little thing she's rubbing
her face
i mean you don't have to sleep there
poke she's like around us yeah she likes
to she likes to be around honestly she
wants to be around yeah
i mean she um you know when i work in
here in my office she sleeps in that
chair like she sits in that chair pretty
much all day yeah she just likes being
around every now and then she comes over
and
jumps on my desk and sticks her butt in
my face so you know she likes to be
around
um somebody said earlier victor said i
had a cousin who only ate frankenberry
cereal till he was like 12. damn did he
get like rickets or
something like that
bad nutrition because i can't imagine
that there are any vitamins in
franken-berry cereal
like i get it's really strange because i
kind of feel like
is it a genetic thing that kids are
naturally averse to
vegetables or anything weird i don't
know if it is because yeah because i've
known the cooking styles i've known some
people that raised their children
just eating whatever and those kids will
just eat whatever yeah and like people
that raise their like you know kids in
other countries aren't like weird about
oh we only have to eat like chicken
nuggets like american kids because we
have southern roots and southerners
overcooked [ __ ] vegetables they
cooked them in they cooked they cooked
them to slime it was terrible
terrible it wasn't until my dad's
generation that they kind of
kind of stopped overcooking vegetables
it's what it was yeah
cheryl says probably keeps them from
getting poisoned
i do kind of think that kids are maybe
more cautious about different things but
i don't know i think it depends a lot on
the upbringing too
our parents were our parents in the
south were influenced by their parents
and their parents were depression-era
yeah
and they were [ __ ] paranoid of
getting sick off of vegetables
could have been that they were using
human waste as fertilizer i don't know
maybe that's because they descended from
sharecroppers true so that might have
been what was happening or maybe there
was an urban legend about that and
everybody believed it or something i
don't know
i think it might have come from the
sharecroppers era yeah
so uh
they uh overcooked especially spinach
spinach was cooked into the [ __ ]
slime yeah my grandma's and they did
kind of they weren't so
they weren't as bad with collard greens
they were cooked though
and then we had things called brussels
sprouts
and i love brussels sprouts a lot of
people didn't like them they're like
little bitty heads of cabbage about the
size of a [ __ ] big old gumball
it came with what we call pot liquor
which is
the drippings from it they had bacon in
it and [ __ ] water and
salt water and
butter butter water i mean you cook
anything in bacon fat it's gonna be good
i don't care what it is sat there and
ate them [ __ ]
[ __ ] brussels sprouts i could sit and
eat a whole [ __ ]
tub of brussels sprouts see there's not
hardly any nutrition in them but the
thing about it is that i never ate them
because my grandma always boiled them
and it smelled like farts yeah um if you
roast them they're delicious
if you boil them they're good too you
just that your grandmother probably
probably overcooked them yeah okay uh
you're not supposed to boil them until
they're just slime they're supposed to
have
consistency and texture too yeah you
know
they're good it's kind of like cabbage
yeah
it's like eating cabbage they're good
making me hungry talking about this i am
kind of hungry yeah we we might go shut
this off
because we always end up talking about
food
we need to get back to our like on the
menu show one of these days
and it's like we started doing that and
then we did like six or seven episodes
and then we like didn't do it anymore
how long we've been going two and a half
hours it's about time
go ahead and shut it down go ahead and
shut it down tom says tom says shout out
yeah i'll cook something to eat
okay sound good yeah all right what are
you gonna make uh i'll get down there
and see what we have okay i have all
kinds of stuff like uh the carnitas are
done i can make tacos right now
yeah you can make tacos or whatever
because we ate the rest of that curry
earlier yeah no i got i only have one
serving
well i had some of that earlier so we'll
get something different okay i can make
uh tacos
oh no i can't or i can make uh burritos
i have a bunch of [ __ ] flour
tortillas that i can do um i think taco
is right over here to be honest with you
i don't have any vegetables but i got
cheese and [ __ ] it's all right it's good
yeah it's all good yeah it's all good
it's all good all right so uh thanks
everybody for dropping by this evening
i'm just so glad we got through the case
it was like like i said maybe i'll try
and keep it to these but i say that now
but that's not going to work out she's
kind of like so much more than she can
actually choose well sometimes i don't
really think about it because sometimes
i'm just thinking of because i'm you
know trying to think of topics like to
put in the poll yeah and so sometimes i
don't really like think things through
like how much work is this going to be
to research yeah um you know what i mean
so sometimes that happens and then i get
into it and i'm just like [ __ ] me why
did i choose this but you know what i
mean so i kind of like this just this
one case uh because it was short and
sweet we got into it we got out of it i
covered everything i wanted to cover so
that was nice all right so uh we're
gonna go have some tacos i guess uh
thank you everybody for dropping by
thank you for your super chats and we
will see you guys on friday evening for
the side track show probably talking
about food again because that's what we
always end up talking about uh so yeah
we'll see you on friday evening and have
a very good rest of your night